Dude,
I'm so happy to be here.
Dude.
I'm so happy you're here.
I've been reading your book and it's
fucking excellent.
You're a really good writer.
Thank you so much.
I killed myself doing that though.
That is the hardest thing I've ever done
in my life.
How long did it take?
That two years.
Wow.
And when I got the deal,
I had this delusional idea that it would
be like writing 25,000 word essays and
this was so wrong.
This was so,
so,
so much harder than anything I'd ever
done.
Why was it so much harder than writing
essays?
Well,
when you write essays,
you are doing like these kinds of short
things.
It's limited.
You have a beginning,
a middle and an end.
No characters,
no dialogue.
You know,
simple narrative.
Where does this man like keeping a plot
together over 300 pages and then that
plot is your life,
which by definition has no plot.
Right?
Oh,
that makes sense.
Yeah,
it was.
It hard to recall all the moments in
your life and do them justice
so hard.
And also for,
for this book,
because I work as a journalist,
I fact checked it as best I could and
nothing is more personally painful than
fact checking the ends of various
friendships and relationships and
realizing what a jerk you were at the
time.
Yeah,
I can only imagine.
Yeah.
I don't want to do that.
Like,
Oh man,
I had a whole victimization narrative.
Oh that was quite the quite wrong think.
Probably did too.
Everybody does.
You know everybody,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really strange when you go back and
talk to people that you haven't talked
to for a long time and you're like,
okay,
what is your,
and you know,
no,
all judgments aside.
Let's just give me your version of what
happened and I'll tell you what I think
happened and you know,
I call my God,
I don't know what the fuck the truth is
anymore.
Yeah.
I have this one thing where there was
this one girl,
she recalled something and she recalled
it one way and then when she realized
that it was actually two days later than
she thought it was,
which made it look like there was an
article she had written,
which had contradicted it.
She kept insisting it hadn't happened.
And I was like,
man,
here's your twitter.
Here's my twitter,
here's the twitter of the two other
people who are at brunch.
Here's the email confirming it had
happened on this day.
And finally she was like,
I just give up.
I give up,
but I don't remember it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's very strange when people are
confronted by that fact too.
Yeah.
I had a,
um,
a friend that I'm no longer friends
with.
It insisted something.
And then when my other friend jumped in
and said,
that's not what happened at all.
It is.
It was a psychedelic drug talk.
I'm trying to avoid beat around the
Bush,
like I'm on regular radio or something.
But,
uh,
he was insisting that he,
got me on this a psychedelic drug the
first time in my,
my other friend was like,
um,
no,
that was mine.
It was my drugs.
I was there like,
what are you talking about man?
And then he just sort of stopped talking
to us,
just like walked off and it comes back
later with a new subject.
Well,
people love
to,
you know,
they love somehow or another to get
glory from the past and lucky somehow or
another it didn't.
It's one of those things that never
works.
Sort of like name dropping,
like name dropping has never worked
ever.
No one has ever said,
I'm really good friends with Leonardo
Dicaprio.
And someone's gone,
Whoa,
let me give you a movie now.
Fucking amazing.
No,
immediately people go,
oh,
this guy's a name dropper.
You know?
Or he just happens to say it.
It happens to be true.
There's a fine line,
but everybody knows what the difference
is.
Like when you're a name dropper comes,
he can,
you could smell it in a sentence,
you know,
it's just like,
it comes off in the air.
So this book is,
um,
it's,
it's fucking super intimate.
Like you,
you like just,
just cut the skin away and open your
chest up and just the whole world could
see your soul.
You know,
you,
you peeled it out.
I tried my best.
I mean I just wanted to do something
honest.
You know what?
It's definitely that I guess.
I mean,
I don't know.
I wasn't there obviously.
Um,
two years is a long time to write
something.
Like did you,
how many times did you have to go back
over it and oh God,
like seven drafts and there's a hundred
pages of cuts from this book too.
That's in another word file that I might
nine seven day for other essays.
But it was like over and over and you
know,
because I had never written a book
before,
I didn't,
I didn't realize,
you know,
how much extra you right.
I feel like I was like building a block
of marble basically out of words.
And then I had to like cut away at the
horrible ugly block of Marble I had
made.
And then finally something cool emerged.
Yeah.
They all say that all the great writers
say that like my friend Steve or always
use this quote,
you have to kill your babies.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what they say,
right?
That's like the common writers
conversation.
Kill your babies,
but then you can keep your babies at
another document and you can devote like
one essay probaby where they make sense.
That sounds similar to stand up comedy
and a lot of ways like one of the
hardest things about comedy isn't
recognizing like I'm a bit,
sometimes it's just too fat,
there's too much stuff in it and you
have to figure out what to chop off.
But you have like these emotional
connections to these punchlines like
upon,
I love this part,
I love saying it.
This is like my favorite part,
but that favorite part doesn't
necessarily enhance the whole thing.
So you have to kind of chip it away and
then the whole thing will be better
without it.
But it's,
it's hard to do.
Right.
Oh God.
I mean,
the best piece I ever,
I've advice I ever got when I started
writing was um,
my friend Laurie,
who's that really cool journalist said
to me,
the worst articles I've ever written are
the ones where I tried to say everything
about a subject.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Well you,
your,
your style is really interesting too
because one of the things that was
really cool,
it's like you've got a lot of
illustrations that go along with these
stories.
Now are these illustrations that you
added in after the fact or the
illustrations that you sort of drew
while you were experiencing these
things?
A few of them I drew at the time.
Like there are some old illustrations
like from Turkey or from Paris that I
did when I was teenager.
Some stuff from occupied,
but I'd say like over a hundred of them
I did new for the book.
Oh Wow.
So that's a lot of extra work on top of
that as well.
Oh my God.
How many days would you doing this every
day?
Or how will you find the time?
Cause I know you're so busy doing
journalism,
you'd be busy doing
art.
Like how'd you find the time to do this?
Um,
I was a really horrible person to be
around for quite a few months.
Uh,
I have the coolest boyfriend in the
world.
Thank you fred for putting up with me
during this fred,
Fred.
Fred is,
Fred is awesome.
I,
I had a few things.
First,
I had friends with a house in the
country and they let me stay there for a
number of weeks and they didn't have
internet signal and a lot of it.
So I,
I didn't bring any of my fun books that
I liked to read.
So I was just stuck.
It was just me in this fucking thing and
we're going to beat each other.
I rented a lot of hotel rooms.
I had an an editor put a beat down on me
and was like,
you can't keep going off to other
countries.
You actually have to write this book
that I contracted you for eye.
And at one point he was like,
are you fleeing towards zone?
So you don't have to look at your book
contract.
Is that how it's going?
I just,
I think towards the end I didn't do
anything but work on it.
I just became this horrible like troll
beast that didn't wash her hair and
would growl at anyone who came near
living entirely in coffee and just made
it.
That was how I did it.
Yeah.
That is a good way to do it.
Right?
If you can get somewhere without the
internet.
Yeah.
I used to write a lot on airplanes.
I so look forward to airplane flights.
I'd be like,
okay,
I'm stuck in this seat.
There's no Internet access.
And then what the fuck do the airlines
do?
They put it
[inaudible] on the God damn planes.
I know.
And then you're like,
oh,
I need to see what someone says about me
on twitter.
Oh no,
someone was wrong on twitter.
I must remedy that.
Go on Amazon and buy a new pair of
sneakers,
you know?
Exactly.
It's so easy to just get distracted
nowadays.
It's just the world is becoming more and
more available,
you know?
And if you're off in a cabin in the
woods with no Internet access,
yeah.
Your,
your,
your stock.
You're,
you're confronted with your own work to
do.
Yeah.
It's so attractive.
That's such an attractive idea.
It'd be off in a cab.
It's so romantic,
right.
To be off in a cabin in the woods by
herself working on your,
your great work.
Except whenever I'm actually there,
I want to like dig holes.
It was in my arms because I'm like,
no,
there is a guy that I tweeted about
today.
Uh,
there was an article that I tweeted
where this guy decided he wanted to live
by himself in the,
uh,
I think it was a northwest territory's
who's going to do it for a solid year
and,
but he made it six months and then he
had a satellite phone.
It's like,
come get me,
I can't fucking do this anymore.
But he was just going crazy like by
himself for six months and it's a,
it's a fascinating story.
This is the guy right here.
Norwegian adventurer spent six months
alone in the north territory.
Holderness and uh,
it's really cool because the guy is,
he is very good at describing like what
he felt and what it was like and what he
expected versus what it was really like.
One of the things that he said that I
thought was really interesting,
he said,
we are not meant to be alone and I kind
of feel that way too.
I feel like I,
you know,
people romanticize this idea of being
this hermit.
It's off in the woods,
you know,
the,
the monk that's out meditating in the
forest by himself,
that shit is
like,
it's like holding your breath.
It's kind of cool for a little while,
but you don't,
you don't want to do it very long.
No,
man,
I think,
I mean,
it makes you go crazy.
Like being in solitary things makes you
go crazy.
I recently did a really big
investigative piece.
I'm on some longterm solitary prisoners
and these guys like were really smart
guys.
They were,
you know,
really,
um,
strong guys in my opinion.
Like one of them,
I consider them really a genius,
but he had been in solitary for 14
years.
Man.
14 years.
And um,
who is this?
His name is Andre Jacobs.
He,
I was part of these group of
whistleblowers called the Dallas six
that,
um,
basically they were giving information
about guards doing,
I'm beating people up and being racist
in this prison in PA and they're all in
solitary and the guards retaliated.
And then when one of the other guys,
Carrington sued the Dea for,
I'm not protecting him from the guards,
the da turned around and charged them
all with rioting.
And I got really into the case cause I
was like,
this seems semantically interesting.
How do you ride if you're in solitary?
I consider riding at group activity.
Like if someone's riding in solitary,
he could just leave them there and they
get tired eventually and then the right
would be over.
You know,
that's hilarious.
He called it rioting.
So they're at,
so I uh,
I did an investigative piece and
eventually I got like video and stuff
but,
and it was bullshit and I really hope
they're trial goes well in February,
but as part of it,
you know,
he spent a lot of time talking to um,
two of the guys and I mean you sat for
real mental trauma from doing that and
like no one,
even like the smartest,
toughest,
best person who has like a really loving
mom that is really devoted to giving
them,
you know,
all the books and all the support,
even that person will suffer like real,
real trauma from that.
Yeah.
I've always wondered like when Bradley
Manning was arrested and then later
became Chelsea manning and spent how
many years was he?
She,
you know,
whenever the transition makes sense.
Uh,
how many years was she in solitary?
Like cool.
Like it was quite a long time and three
years I think.
Naked.
Yeah.
Naked and in cold conditions,
like they literally tortured her,
like take tortured her.
Like they,
what they decided when do you,
when do you say her and when his him,
cause when did she decide to transition?
When she was in there.
Right.
Yeah.
See,
like announce the transition,
um,
right after her trial.
But she,
um,
I mean if you look at her chat logs with
Adrian Lamo,
she has one line where she says that
what she's afraid of is being known to
the world as a boy.
So I think,
I think she decided herself along a long
time ago,
but before she was arrested,
yeah.
Before she was arrested,
but that she just didn't publicly
announce it for a long time.
That is a crazy,
the worst things to be known as a boy.
Yeah.
Whoa.
It was a,
it was a line from the chat log.
And anyone who's listening to this,
like,
please fact check it.
I don't want to get it wrong,
but that's what I remember.
But I remember thinking
like,
who wouldn't lose their fucking mind
being naked in a room by herself for
years?
Like what did they,
they thought that she was a,
um,
a hazard to ourself or something.
They're,
they're,
they're bullshit excuses where he's
like,
oh,
you're a suicide risk so we have to have
you naked with no glasses,
nothing to read,
a horrible like suicide prevention
blanket that you can't like,
you know,
wrap around you and just,
we have to like torture here cause he
might be a suicide risk.
Like is she in like regular prison now
or still in solitary?
She's in regular prison right now
actually like one of my most cherished
possessions in the university.
She wrote me a letter once cause I,
I drew a birthday card for her.
She dots her i's with little doves.
It's really cute with doves.
Yeah.
She draws little doves on them.
Every I,
yeah.
I hope this isn't a long letter now as a
short one.
Is that it was a gracious one.
It wasn't me.
It was,
I think it,
it reminded me of like,
you know,
the thank you card that like someone
very graciously,
right.
Someone who's giving them a gift.
But what a bizarre set of circumstances.
Someone who was a soldier who transition
to becoming a woman and then sends
letters at all,
have the,
the animal that's known as the symbol of
peace.
Yeah.
Over all the eyes.
I mean,
I think from her life you get the sense
that part of the reason she wants to
join the army,
but she's just like so smart and she
just wanted to go to college.
I mean,
I'm,
from what I know kind of about reading
her life story like this,
this was someone who like her happiest
time was like dating a dude who is
around sort of like the mit hacker
scene.
And I think that if she was middle class
and not poor,
she just would have like gone to school
and gotten a computer science degree and
that would have been the whole thing.
It's incredible that someone who exposes
crimes
and that's uh,
that's the only way you could look at
what happened with Edward Snowden end
with Bradley Manning.
I mean,
you could say that they did,
what they did was treasonous you get
isn't really treasonous when you're
exposing crime.
Like,
isn't it supposed to be illegal to
commit crime?
And if your government is doing things
that are illegal,
isn't it your job as a patriot to expose
those things?
Like when do you,
when is it not treasonous?
Oh God,
yeah.
I mean they're,
both of them are heroes.
Um,
if no one is putting their own
government in check,
then that government will just tend to
concentrating more and more power and
people in it will concentrate to doing
worse and worse things cause there's no
sort of supervision and there's no way
that you can love your country and I'll
call it on.
It's bullshit at all.
I think that the opposite thing is
treason.
I think it's treason to say like,
just because it's my country,
any crime is justified
with a,
what they're doing though is so horrible
because they're making it so that no one
ever does anything like this.
Again,
it's so they make such a giant example.
Like Julian assange is literally like
going crazy.
The staying in that one house in,
in London,
he can't leave if he leaves the arrest
him the moment he steps foot on that.
Like what a crazy thing.
Like he can get out in the balcony and
wave to people and get a slight amount
of vitamin D and then he has to go back
inside and he's fucking trapped.
Snowden is hanging out with Putin and
Russia,
which is just bizarre to me.
So strange.
I watched a bizarre Putin video today.
Which food and video did he watch?
Hooten they're analyzing his gait the
way he walks.
So creepy.
Like why don't they just admit that they
like have a crush on him and one have a
sleep over?
That is so weird.
I mean,
well it's because he has a very specific
way of walking that's indicative of
someone who has military training.
It's called the gunslingers gate as I
did.
Did they make that term up themselves?
I guess they probably did,
but what he does is he swings his left
arm but not his right,
so he could pull his gun out really
quickly.
That's the idea.
But what's really bizarre about the
video is I didn't know how like opulent
wherever he is,
what palace or whatever the fuck it is.
Like they have these fucking ignore it.
Like here it is,
look at these.
He norm is gold doors.
Like let's play it.
Let's play at Jamie.
So he could watch this.
Like if you watch as he walks,
if you notice his left arm swings
noticeably while his right arm stays
relatively still in comparison,
like a huge contrast.
And he always does this and that's so
that he could shoot you in the fucking
head quicker.
I think I got someone finds out there's
an untreated rotator cuff injury and one
of the that's true,
right?
We're just like looking way too into it.
But apparently it's really common
amongst these guys in the Russian
military that,
uh,
get that move to some form of political
power.
But what's kind of creepy?
It's about it.
Backing up to the beginning again,
Jamie,
please.
Um,
what's creepy it's about is look at
those fucking doors.
Like what is that like?
What are those God damn doors.
Look at all that gold.
Everything's gold.
I mean,
I guess that's the vestiges of being an
imperial power where people used to
collect faberge eggs and he is,
I mean,
he is one of the most open dictators
that you can see in modern society in
which it's supposed to be some sort of a
democracy.
I'm not entirely familiar with how the
Russians run their political system,
but I know that he was out and then he
was,
you know,
he puts some other guy and some sort of
a puppet position and now he's back
running the whole show.
But it's,
it's,
he's a weird case man.
I don't know how he manages it.
It seems like guys like that someone
always wants to kill them and just,
it always falls apart.
But he's managed to keep it together for
a long,
long,
long time.
Now.
He is,
I mean,
I can't say,
I'm like super familiar with Russian
politics,
so I could,
I might be talking bullshit,
but I mean,
he,
you know,
he was the ex head of the KGB.
Like he seems incredibly versed and
spying on people and killing people who
are threats and maintaining his position
at all costs.
Yeah.
He doesn't just kill him.
He kills him like openly.
Yeah.
Hasn't gotten down in front of their
girlfriends and stuff like that.
He's just,
it's just it massive terror tactic.
Who was that one guy that was,
yeah,
he was walking with his girlfriend and
his thought was that he had become so
famous from criticizing and the Putin
couldn't kill him because if he did it
would be so obvious.
Nope.
No,
he doesn't care.
I mean,
I always think about,
um,
there is a very respected,
a journalist whose name,
last name I won't pronounce cause I'll,
I'll butcher it.
But um,
yeah,
she was also just like gunned down for
criticizing him.
Yeah.
Well that's kind of happened sort or
fear for theoretically at least in other
places.
But one on one of the weird ones in
America was that Michael Hastings Guy,
that guy.
That's a,
that's still,
that one really freaks me out to this
day.
Cause if you don't know the story,
Michael Hastings was,
there's actually a ted talk,
um,
that's available right now.
It's,
I'm a podcast called the Ted Radio Hour,
which I listened to all the time that
had,
um,
one episode called disruptive
leadership,
but it actually focused on this general
general mcallister.
And they were kind of sympathetic to him
in this,
in this Ted talk because,
uh,
the idea was that he did a real
leadership thing by stepping down and
what,
what it was was Michael Hastings had
gotten embedded in this military
organization,
whether they were overseas and when the
volcano erupted,
remember that volcano in Iceland,
it erupted and it's fucked up all the
flights out of Europe and a,
you couldn't fly from that part of the
world to this part of the world.
So,
uh,
he got stuck.
It was supposed to be a short trip and
he got stuck over there for a month.
And as he got closer and closer to these
people,
they've got more and more relaxed and
they started telling jokes that were
inappropriate about like Al Gore and,
or Joseph Biden.
And,
um,
along the lines of this,
this Guy Michael Hastings formulated
this article,
published it in rolling stone and um,
it became this sort of a national
scandal and I believe his name is Miguel
Esta right?
Is that his name?
He,
um,
he was forced to step down and that's
what the whole focus of this ted radio
hour was about was this guy,
um,
taking a leadership position,
a leadership point of view by deciding
that his position was not as important
as the cause itself.
And he was just going to step down
because he had created this environment
where it was too much controversy and he
was upset that,
um,
President Obama didn't ask him to stay,
but it is what it is and that's it.
But what they don't say in this thing
was just Michael Hastings guy who was in
this recording,
who's talking about what it was like
when he was there and he committed
suicide in one of the strangest,
most controversial ways ever.
I don't think it was a suicide.
I think it was an accident.
Well,
some people think it was a suicide.
Some people think it was an accident and
that the black helicopter crew thinks
that he
was murdered and that what they did is
they took over the electronics in his
Mercedes and they forced his car to
drive right into a tree at 120 miles an
hour with no brakes and explode.
And let me,
there's all this crazy,
all these crazy conspiracy theories that
are attached to it that say that engines
don't go flying from a car like that
unless there's a bomb involved.
And you know,
like,
why would this guy do this?
And it is pretty,
pretty trippy stuff.
And then there was claims that there was
crystal meth in his system and then he
was,
you know,
high on drugs and he had a problem with
drugs in the past.
But then the counter to that was people
were like,
well,
no,
he's probably doing adderall,
which a lot of writers do.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
It's like the New York drug.
Everyone's on adderall in New York,
is it?
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I know a lot of people who were very
close to,
to Michael Hastings and,
um,
I will say that people that I know that
are very close to him think it was a
tragic accident.
They just happened to be going 120 miles
an hour on sunset boulevard.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's for the people I know that,
you know,
he never hit his brakes.
I,
I can't,
I can't debate it.
But that's,
that's just what I've heard from people,
from people who I'm very close to who
are close to him.
I would say that too,
if I was close to that dude,
I knew I was on some sort of a list.
If you're close to that guy,
you know,
you gotta be on a list.
Oh my God.
Well,
I mean probably like if you're an
investigative journalist doing a lot of
stuff in Iraq and Somalia,
you're probably on the list.
You're talking about yourself.
Uh,
I haven't done Somalia stuff.
Um,
no,
I mean,
but like a lot of his friends were
investigative journalists.
Yeah,
I'm sure everybody's,
I'm a,
I'm probably on the list,
probably analyst for having you right
here.
Dude.
I know you dude.
I'm in California.
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm adopting adopting the a in the
native dialect.
I,
I'm sure we're all on lists because how
could you be interesting if you're not
on the list?
That's true.
It's sort of like a badge of courage to
be on some sort of a list.
Depends on what lists though,
you know.
But uh,
yeah,
it's a weird world we live in right now.
I think it's a,
it's,
there's a temporary bridge right now.
Let's go on,
on where,
where there,
it's the NSA,
you know,
fill in the blank with whatever name of
whatever organization that's supposedly
watching over us.
But they have a certain amount of power
to look into people that we don't have
yet that's temporary.
It is going to come a time where this
electronic barrier that we have in
between each other,
it's all going to dissolve and
everyone's going to have the same sort
of power to spy on everybody at the NSA
has.
And we're just going to have to accept
it.
It's going to be very straight.
It's going to be like we're all camping.
Oh okay.
God's going to horrifying worlds.
We already know too much about each
other.
We
do.
Right.
Was that a concern when you were writing
this book cause you empty yourself out
in this book.
I mean you talk about sexual liaisons
and you know,
relationships and friendships and things
gone wrong and was,
did you,
when you were writing this,
did you ever say,
man,
I mean maybe I don't want everybody
didn't know these things.
I had a few things that were like that
usually with actually with friendships,
but ultimately I thought that it was
more important to be honest though,
the one thing that I did do was I felt
like it would have been really unfair if
I had taken kind of,
you know,
personal moments I had with someone like
15 years ago and just like put them in a
book and that's on that person's google
result without asking them.
So while I tried to be pretty merciless
with myself,
with people who I'm still friends with,
I got their approval on what I wrote
about them.
Oh,
that's really cool.
That's it.
That's really important.
That would be a real good way to destroy
a friendship who started telling crazy,
intimate stories about someone just not
cool.
Like it's not,
it's not fair.
You know?
So,
and I know that light,
a lot of people disagree with that and
they're like,
they're my memories.
But I don't know.
I don't think it's right.
Especially if you're kind of the more
famous one.
It not cool.
Yeah,
we'll sing there.
My memories.
But if you share a moment with someone,
I think it's kind of a group memory or
at least a group moment.
Yeah.
It's kind of kind of collectively owned.
And I,
I ran them by my parents also.
Dad's gotta be weird.
That was the most terrifying thing.
And there is the,
cause I ran the parts about my parents
buy them,
but then they hadn't read the whole
book.
And I had this really terrifying thing
when the book came out where I was like,
oh my God,
what are they going to think?
I mean,
I love my parents.
I have really supportive relationship.
I couldn't ask for like two cooler
people on Earth unit knew my parents.
But still you're always scared,
right?
It's,
it's scary to show yourself like that
but,
but they liked it.
They liked it mostly.
So I'm very happy about that.
While you must have really open minded
parents.
My Mama,
she used to be an illustrator and now
she's mostly retired.
She works kind of as a babysitter slash
cats that are now and um,
my dad and my dad's an academic.
Oh that's cool.
Well,
so yeah,
you seem obviously have some intelligent
open minded parents so they've got to be
really proud of you cause this is
excellent stuff.
Thank you so much.
Yeah,
they really are.
And um,
it was cool because I got to talk about
how both of them influenced me so much
in there.
Totally,
totally different ways.
Like my mom is an amazing artist.
She,
she trusts so beautifully and she draws
kind of like me.
If I was a less bitter and jagged person
like,
like she drives like the sweet me and I
was able to say like,
this is how my mom taught me how to
draw.
You know,
this is how she inspired me.
You've got some great people that are
reviewed this too,
man.
You got Matt Taibbi to review this.
Patton Oswald reviewed this.
I mean this is really fucking impressive
stuff.
Thank you.
And that,
that's awesome.
He actually interviewed me for my book
launch in New York and I grew up reading
that,
you know,
I was reading like the exile when I was
18 and I,
I love his stuff in New York press.
And what I love about Matt's work is
that a lot of journalists like,
they're like these really like narrow
professional people that are very,
very serious.
And Matt was like this total wild man
and he was yelling and now he does this
incredible investigative journalism on
finance and politics,
but he still writes like a real person.
He still writes and that kind of hunter
s Thompson tone.
That's exactly,
I was going to describe it like a lucid
hunters Thompson.
Exactly.
Like this drug addled
yeah,
yeah.
Best of hunter s Thompson and less
narcissistic bit and we know much less
narcissistic now,
but it was so influential on me cause I
was like,
wow,
you can totally be this bad ass
investigative journalist and you could
also be this guy who when he was young
was having these crazies often criminal
adventures in like the aftermath of the
Soviet Union falling.
Those two things weren't nodding
compatible at all.
I,
I always liked people like that who have
lives that are really,
really diverse.
Yeah,
that's a really good way of describing
him too because we do have this idea
that if you're going to be an
investigative journalist that your piece
has to be sort of homogenized and that
is going to the,
the facts take precedent over the flavor
of the pros and his has a lot of flavor.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of personality in
distributing those facts,
but it doesn't get in the way of the
facts.
Oh God,
no,
he's,
it's,
it's such like a master class on how to
do it.
And in fact it's really serves the
facts.
Cause especially when he's writing about
financial journalism,
I mean,
finance can be so boring and so
complicated that it can really be over
most people's heads.
And if you write it completely without
flavor,
most people will never even be able to
sink into it at all.
Yeah.
Is
Guy that I got most of my information
about the financial collapse about,
and one of the things that disturbed me
the most was how little reaction like
publicly his articles caused.
Like I thought like it would be one of
those things where everyone would be
sharing it.
It would go,
it would be on the front page of the New
York Times today on CNN,
Matt Taibbi uncover.
And everybody would be like,
Ooh,
look at the facts.
This is crazy.
But meanwhile it was like this terrible,
terrible scenario where the whole system
was hijacked by these fucking criminals
and no one seemed to care.
It just w I have bills to pay,
I have to keep going.
I have a spin class at nine o'clock I
can't be paying and no one,
no one really gave it the attention or I
shouldn't say no one but not publicly
nationally.
It didn't get nearly the attention that
it deserves and he wrote a series of
them and you know,
some of them I was like,
this guy's going to get fucking killed.
Like these were,
these were intense allegations and it's
it and backed up.
All of it backed up by facts and really
well written and it's just like almost
like it's too much for people.
This is like,
it's like complicated.
It deals with a lot of things that are
kind of boring,
very intellectually demanding,
not necessarily partisan.
And I think for a lot of people are
like,
what are you going to do?
Yeah,
it bothers me that he's not more famous.
That bothers me.
I think.
I hope with the next book he will be,
cause I think he's like one of the best
journalists working in American.
Yeah,
I agree.
He's,
he's amazing.
He's amazing.
Now you,
how much time do you spend doing all
this?
You too.
A lot of journalism and you do a lot of
crazy shit.
You go to a really nutty sort of
dangerous places.
I've been to a few.
Yeah.
What is like the most disturbing place
that you've been to?
Dangerous place I went to was last
summer when I went into Syria for a day.
And that was,
um,
basically the reason why when I talk
about how dangerous it was,
the fact that I wouldn't even spend the
night there shows probably something
about my tolerance levels.
But at that time,
this coalition of Islamist groups had
just kicked isis out of this border town
called is Oz.
And you could take a bus over to the
Turkish border and then you could cross.
And I did that with a war journalist
friend of mine and I spent a day with
the Islamic Front driving around his
eyes.
And one of the things,
um,
that was happening then was it was
before,
uh,
James Foley was murdered,
but we all knew that there were lots and
lots of kidnappings there.
And at that point we thought it was just
for ransom and stuff,
but still,
you know,
it's Kinda brings a terrible,
terrible thing.
And when,
um,
the scariest thing that ever happened to
me as a journalist was we're with these
three,
a young media activist slash fighter
guys,
really cool dudes.
I mean,
I liked them and we're in this car,
we're driving around his eyes and the
car slows to a halt.
It just breaks down.
And Patrick,
the guy I'm with and immediately thinks
it's set up for kidnapping to,
you know,
get,
get us out of the car because that's one
way that you can set things up for
kidnappings.
And the guys didn't have their guns.
And so we had to walk to the media
office,
um,
through his eyes and his eyes at that
point looked like something out of Mad
Max.
Like it was just no women on the street,
just men.
A lot of Ak is,
uh,
even if a guy didn't have any k like
they'd be holding like sticks and stuff.
Um,
they are,
were,
well there was a like what I can only
describe as like a gun bodega,
which is fascinating because it's sold
all these different guns.
Like it might sound like a beautiful
antique,
you know,
Pearl in laid revolver that like
someone's dad had,
but then also grenades and stuff and
grenades.
Grenades.
Yeah.
Because you know,
in case someone tried to kidnap you,
you could have it grab a fucking,
you come with me bitch.
Yeah.
Basically.
So,
you know,
we're walking through this town and um,
that was I'd think the scariest thing
that I ever did in my life.
But it all turned out fine.
And we got to the media office,
which it was a government building that
they,
that these young men had taken over when
they kicked out the central government.
And I'm the director of it had been
kidnapped by Isis and the young guys are
there like watching,
watching soccer cause everyone,
everyone loves soccer there.
And it was just,
I don't know,
it's like
this feeling of being in place where,
um,
the whole world is both fucking with it
and abandoned it both at once,
you know,
and,
um,
and anything could happen.
So that was the most dangerous thing
I've ever done.
Like nothing I've ever done was as
dangerous is going to Syria.
But I think the most dot personally
disturbing thing was,
um,
I was in a Gaza six months ago,
I guess.
And I went to shy IA,
which is this neighborhood that was
completely destroyed by Israel during
protective edge.
Like they bombed it and then they went
in with tanks and then they went in with
bulldozers.
Like,
so it's like flattened and it's just
like gone.
Like,
you know,
you,
you go there and you're like,
this is,
this is a neighborhood that has been
wrecked.
And a lot of times when you see houses
that have collapsed,
you can see all of the stuff of people's
lives and it like,
you're like,
oh,
there's the cooking pots and there's the
bed and there's all the stuff that's
just trapped in.
And then people,
because there's a big housing shortage
obviously in Gaza,
we're living in these bombed out
buildings,
you know,
where their home was.
And um,
you know,
with like no real like services or
anything.
Like I saw this,
I was walking,
it was kind of scrambling through this
like building take pictures and then I
just randomly walked into what I thought
was an abandoned room and there's like
an old guy there,
you know,
hanging out and you know,
I was like,
I'm really sorry to do,
you know,
invade,
invade your home.
And I was just just talking to him.
But yeah,
he had had like a,
a baller gorgeous home before this and
now he was just living in a little like
the rack of one of the rooms.
Wow.
It's,
you know,
the Mad Max is the way you described
that,
that city and that sort of apocalyptic
scenario,
something that we all worry could happen
to us,
to anything.
But one of the things that I always try
to remember is that the apocalypse is
already here.
It's just not here.
Yeah.
If you go there,
it's there.
Like in Gaza,
it's there,
that's the apocalypse.
It's there.
I mean it might as well be in that guy's
house.
I mean you are living like Mad Max,
those people in that,
what's the name of the city yet?
I saw as,
as,
as and as Oz mean daddy is what
everyone's terrified of.
What everyone's terrified of is a
reality where you walked on the street
and everyone's carrying military weapons
and you're just,
it's chaos and there's,
it's fairly lawless.
Yeah.
I mean a lot of the refugee camps that I
saw it,
it's not that they were lawless.
I would never describe them as that,
but just in the sense of the extreme of
falling in your life situation.
There is a guy I met when I was in Iraqi
Kurdistan.
Uh,
last time I was with Dr Borders there
and he,
you know,
he was this like super smart dude.
Like he was Kurdish,
which meant that he was really
discriminated against,
but he scored so high on his math exams.
He was able to go to like an elite
engineering school and get an
aeronautics degree.
And know be,
he's never not extend engineer.
And like,
this is a dude that would,
you know,
be beyond the path to like having an
awesome job.
And now like he's living in a tent with
his whole family and his mom and
everything.
And you know,
you'd never expect that when you're
living in like an awesome city like
Aleppo that he was living in.
And then you're,
and then the war comes and there's
bombings and here you're driven out of
your home and you're so displaced that
eventually you're forced to,
you know,
be living in this tent with no end in
sight and you're not allowed to like
ever improve your circumstances because
you have the wrong passport.
Jesus Christ.
It's hard for anybody living in America
to wrap their head around what it would
be like to be there and be stuck in that
position.
It really is.
I mean,
so the Syrian refugee,
mm.
Um,
the Syrian refugee thing,
one thing that I,
I think perhaps isn't in the media
enough is that the people who are coming
to Europe right now,
or the middle class of the country,
because it's cost over a thousand
dollars to pay it,
to pay that pass smuggler to take you
over.
And every single one of those people
could buy a plane ticket and travel like
a normal person and not have their kids
risk drowning and all of that.
But they're banned from it cause they're
Syrians.
And the whole like taking the boat and
walking from Greece to Germany and
having volunteers give out water and
sleeping on the streets and like the
whole humanitarian disaster is just a
function of not letting them buy plane
tickets.
That all,
that's all it is.
Well,
there's this big push in America now,
especially among the Republicans not
allow anyone from Syria to come into the
United States.
It's crazy.
Like not a single person with the Syrian
refugee program has ever been arrested
for terrorism offense.
It's,
it's like it's nuts.
it's solar brown,
but they're so scary.
They're terrorist.
Oh my God.
It's like one of them that's an asshole.
I'm sure.
I'm sure there's assholes,
but not one of them was arrested for
terrorism offenses.
If you look like a million Canadians and
you're going to,
and they're the nicest people ever,
there'd be like some of those guys that
are in that,
that big like ride was in Toronto.
It's washing cars.
Yeah.
One of the ones the size asking a car
or one of them from the Vancouver.
A hockey riot.
Yeah.
Those assholes would make it through.
No,
it's,
it's crazy.
And it's,
um,
it's really like personally upsetting to
me because I've done so much,
you know,
work with Syrians over the last few
years and like to see these like amazing
people that I know who are so tough and
so smart and have endured so much.
Like being defamed like this,
it's,
I feel almost like someone's shit
talking like my,
like my,
well,
someone that's shit talking my friends,
you know,
it,
it makes me angry on,
um,
a personal level,
like not just a theoretical one.
Well,
it's not just,
it's,
it's so short sighted because if you
consider the fact that you're,
you're talking about an entire group of
people that's fleeing a terrible area.
Exactly what you're saying.
Well,
they have all got to be bad.
That that's one of the most racist
things that you could ever say publicly
in 2015 it gets sort of this weird
excepted racism.
And because of the fact that terrorism,
it,
like when you're dealing with Muslims,
right?
You're dealing with 1.6 is that what it
is?
Billion people,
like a fifth of the world.
And so the idea is saying,
well,
lead terrorist activities been,
they have been done by Muslims.
Why don't we kick all the white people
out of America?
Because white people have been
responsible for all the mass shootings.
I mean,
that's more logical than this.
It's so awful.
And like the other thing that's to me
like particularly like Moronic is I see
some times in the media like,
why aren't the Muslims condemning the
terrorists?
Every single group that is actually on
the ground,
like fighting isis with guns.
You know,
they're Muslims.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're like 90% Muslim or 95% Muslim.
I mean a lot of them are war criminals
too.
I'm not saying they're good groups
necessarily,
but they're Muslim.
Um,
every single,
like major Muslim religious leader in
the world has condemned isis in terms
that they wouldn't even use an America.
I mean,
it's astounding to me.
I think that the only reason anyone
would think that Muslims are and
condemning isis is because they can't
use google.
Don't read the news and have never
spoken to a Muslim or for the same
reason why Matt Taibbi abies articles
never really got as popular as I thought
they should.
People just don't have the time or the
need.
Everything is wonderful.
You go to the supermarket,
you buy food,
it's really easy.
You know,
go through the Mcdonald's,
drive through your stomach's full.
You sit home and watch netflix.
You're good.
Like you don't need to pay attention to
Syria.
Fuck those people.
Keep them out.
Donald Trump's going to keep us safe and
you got to drink yourself into a coma.
Wake up in the morning,
do it all over again.
Drink some coffee,
get out the door,
get your fucking car,
do the same shit.
As long as you can get to work.
I got bills.
As long as you can get to work,
you're fine.
It's just the idea of America in the
first place was supposed to be a place
where people could go or they didn't
like where they were and they wanted a
found,
they wanted to establish a new life.
They want it to,
we're going to take a giant chance.
We're going to get an a fucking stupid
boat and make it across this giant body
of water.
We don't even know what it looks like.
They didn't have photos back then.
That's one of the weirdest things about
traveling to America.
If you really stop and think about it,
it was done when people didn't even have
photographs.
The first people that came over,
if you wanted a picture of something,
you had to fucking draw it right.
And that's how crazy these people where
they're like,
I don't care.
I saw drawing.
It's a pretty trees.
We're fucking getting in the boat.
But they brought their babies and the
grandma and shit and they got in a boat
and they came to America because they
had an idea and then idea was there is a
better life here we can,
we can make it and the to deny that to
these people because they were born in
the wrong patch of dirt.
And I'm not saying they shouldn't be
checked.
You shouldn't go through a criminal
background check and make sure you're
not letting in some mass murderer or not
letting in some rapist or some thieves
or whatever.
Yeah.
I mean if there's a way to do that,
that should be done.
But the idea that you should never let
anybody in that's from Syria.
It's like God man,
imagine you're cursed.
You just cause you were born in the the
shitty patch of dirt.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's exactly what the thinking is.
It's like because you were born here
like oh you carry some virus,
you have to be quarantined.
Didn't man.
I'm like,
I'm so,
I'm so fucking grateful that you're
saying this is like,
Gee,
your audience and with like on the
massive platform you have.
Like I,
I know it sounds sappy and shit,
but like,
thank you.
I really,
yeah.
Well listen,
thank you for going over there.
If it wasn't for people like you and,
and you know the,
the vice people and all these
journalists and all these people that go
over there and show us in,
in video form,
like exactly what's happening.
And you get to watch it and see what
it's like.
They go,
oh,
this is fucking chaos.
Like this is in the world right now.
2015 while people were watching the
emmy's and everybody's on the red carpet
smiling.
There's parts of the world that are like
a Mad Max movie right now.
Or like this refugee camp.
Um,
I went to,
er,
it was a bunch of refugee camps in the
Bekaa Valley in Lebanon.
Like,
people don't know it gets cold.
They're like kids freeze to death.
You know,
every winter I'm in those camps cause
it's like you're living under vinyl tarp
in the mountains.
Jesus Christ.
It's,
it's very strange that the world is so
uneven that there are places like the
Congo that are like,
that exist on the same timeline as park
avenue,
that there's,
there's people that have door men that
dress up like the guys that were holding
open the door for Putin,
hop into Uber,
limousines,
and you travel around the city,
you know,
with the right fragrances and the in the
car.
And it's,
it's,
we will live in really strange times
because I think the disparity that
existed that that's kind of always
existed.
There's always been disparity.
There's always been,
you know,
the haves and the have nots.
And in some places it's on a much more
grand scale,
but it's never been so obvious,
especially cause
so many people are online now.
Like I think a lot of people maybe don't
realize that.
Okay.
Especially in the Middle East,
like how Internet connected people are.
When I was in dummies,
which is this a refuge,
it was the refugee camp in Iraq that I,
that I was at.
One of the most popular stories was the
store that was selling personal wifi
hotspots.
And you'd have people that were living
in like a tent,
you know,
with tarp and like nothing,
but they'd have like a wifi hotspot and
that's because they had a family that
was scattered all around the world.
And the only way to communicate them
with them was with whatsapp or with
texting services like this or with
skype.
And so like the most important thing you
were going to get was Internet access so
that you could like talk to your brother
that was in one country and your
daughter that was in another like that
was more important than anything
you said,
daughter,
I'd heard your using.
Oh fuck.
It's coming out man.
I tried so hard.
I did it.
Yeah.
And I,
yeah,
it's,
it's true.
I'm from Queens originally.
Well,
you know,
it's Kinda crazy is I guarantee you
it's,
it is a high possibility that someone in
one of those camps is listening to you
right now.
Oh,
absolutely.
Podcasts that have downloaded it from
the Internet.
No,
it's absolutely,
it's absolutely true.
Um,
I wonder,
I feel like if you're like,
if someone who's listening is listening,
you know,
from a camper is listening,
in a refugee situation like I man,
how cool would it be to get someone like
that on your show as a guest?
If there is like a way with skype or
something,
that'd be amazing.
I have to clear it with Donald Trump.
Make sure he thinks or our Syrian voices
allowed into the country or would that
cause isis,
does isis come from Syrian voices?
It's a disease of the mind.
He wants to stop the Internet to the
Middle East.
Have you heard this?
This is the latest Donald Trump thing.
I had a signing last night,
so I unfortunately I missed the
intellectual glory.
That was the republican debate.
So fill me in on this.
Okay.
Didn't see it.
But he was talking about this,
that one of the things that they would
do or he would do is knock off the
internet to certain parts of the Middle
East.
Why like how's that?
Well,
because that's how they're plotting
against us.
Molly crab apple while you sit in your
wonderful New York apartment writing
books about sex,
the terrorists,
the terrorists are winning.
Oh God.
I mean does so in Isis territories that
those fuckers are occupying,
they got rid of private Internet access
in people's homes because they're really
scared of the Internet.
Two,
they are super scared because there are
all these citizen activists and
journalists that are revealing shit
about them on the Internet right now.
Like if you're in rock cod,
the only way to even get online is to be
on these Internet cafes that are kind of
run by dudes with Isis connections.
Whoa.
And,
and um,
that's because isis is also really
fucking scared of the Internet.
They really don't like it.
Really?
Yeah.
Why is that?
Well,
because a lot of Syrians living and
Iraqis living in their territories
fucking hate them and they give Intel on
them.
Two,
um,
foreign journalists.
That's fascinating.
So the Internet acts as a way that they
communicate and establish plans,
but it also acts as something that's
plotting against them.
Exactly.
Same as the internet does it everywhere
else.
No,
I mean,
it's just communication.
It's just people.
Yeah.
When you're a group of [inaudible] that
the whole world hates and your online
guarantee,
you're going to get some haters.
Yeah.
I mean there's a,
there's one group of,
um,
journalists there that became very
famous that's called Brocka as being
silently slaughtered that,
I mean they did tons of work documenting
isis shit and isis,
I mean beheaded two of their members
that were in Turkey and there are plenty
of other citizen journalists there and
yeah,
isis is dead scared of normal of normal
people who are living under their
fucking occupation using the internet.
They hate it.
You know,
another thing,
they're scared,
they're scared of being killed by women.
So that's kind of,
I think,
I think
this is my theory that um,
the Kurdish group,
they won't go to heaven if a curtis girl
kills them thing.
I think like one person said that and
then it still how much play it got in
the media and they were like,
aw man,
this is good pr.
Let's keep it,
let's keep milking this one.
I think so,
yeah.
That's,
it makes sense.
Ideologically,
like within their religion.
Is that something that they believe in?
She get killed by a woman.
You don't get all the virgins.
No,
I think that's bullshit.
I think that would be,
I think maybe there's like a macho
thing,
you know where they're like,
well fuck a girl,
girl shot my leg,
but I,
it's not a theological thing.
Damn.
It seems so good though.
I know.
It really,
it seemed,
it seems sweet,
like some crazy Amazon scenario
chasing isis and they just run away
because they're scared of being killed
by the women who are fighting Isis in
the Ypj or you know,
ferocious soldiers.
But either isis is scared of getting,
they're scared of getting killed.
Our soldiers were really allocated or if
that was true though,
allocated our resources correctly,
I think there's probably enough really
mean bitches in the world.
We could put together a hell of a
fucking army.
I think so.
I think so too,
with tons of motivation.
Could you imagine just jet jetson
bombers
piloted by women?
Like that's it.
Only women.
Only women going after Isis because if
they get killed by these women,
there are Fox and they don't get to go
to heaven.
I think.
I think you'd have to do like a more,
I think at the bombings aren't doing
shit against Isis.
I think the Ypg is doing is,
you know,
I think I'd have to be more on the
ground.
Well,
especially in Afghanistan,
right?
That's one of the things that people
have always had a problem with invading
Afghanistan.
It's essentially a series of mountain
ranges occupied by warlords.
There's not like,
there's not a lot of access.
It's not so easy to get to.
The thing with Isis is what they do is
they,
I mean they move in,
they occupy cities like a military
occupation and they try to marry people
and build families and they try to
insert themselves as much as possible
into the fabric of a city.
And that's partially,
in part,
it's them making it so that if,
if you,
you know,
bombed Rocca,
he would be murdering hundreds of
thousands of innocent civilians who were
just too poor to get out to do it.
Strategically embed themselves as a
human shield.
Yeah,
exactly.
And like there were,
I mean the majority of Rocca is there
like farmers who couldn't afford to get
out because it's expensive to even get
out of Syria.
What a mess.
What a crazy,
chaotic,
psychotic mess.
It's really bizarre.
That member,
that Obama speech that he had on
television,
was it a year or so ago or he was
talking about eminent military action
against Syria and the whole country
went,
what are you fucking crazy?
And then it just,
it just stopped.
Literally like silence.
Like you didn't hear anything more about
it.
They just completely backed off just
because Republicans and Democrats,
everyone was like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
Like what could happen in look what
happened
in Afghanistan?
Look at the,
the massive negative reaction the
American public has had all these
military actions.
You're going to start up a new one on in
Syria for what reason?
Because somebody got gassed because they
gas people.
Like what do you,
what you,
what's going on that we need to
sacrifice American lives over there.
Exactly.
Like what's the cause of all this?
I mean,
what's really sort of a so tragic about
Syria is that,
um,
Obama,
this,
this is me saying an opinion that's not
necessarily mine,
but it's opinion of that I've gotten
from speaking to refugees.
It,
um,
a lot of people I think felt very led on
by what Obama said and they felt like,
oh,
there's going to be,
you know,
some support or I don't know,
some action against Assad because I mean
whatever one thinks about American
intervention or not intervention,
what asides did is a crime against
humanity on a massive scale.
What,
whatever we think do you think we should
have done what he did was fucking
horrific.
And anyone who is in Syria and you know
who was at the receiving end of that
would very often once someone else to
intervene and explain to people what he
did do,
he ran like an industrial scale,
um,
arrest,
torture killing program.
He does something called barrel
bombings,
which are taking like basically like
dumpsters full of t and t and shrapnel
and dropping them in populated areas to
target schools,
targets.
Hospitals are destroyed.
A large swathes of Aleppo.
And this isn't,
this isn't me saying,
um,
this isn't me saying that I think the US
should have intervened because I,
I,
I still don't know.
But I,
I'm very against the US intervening in
general and anything cause I think we
always fuck it up.
But he also factually didn't do those
things.
It's just hard to imagine that someone
is capable of doing shit like that
where people can get to,
where people can get through in their
minds that the,
that allows them to do shit like that.
I think what it was was his,
one of the things that was quite
influential was his father put down,
I'm sort of incipient insurgency
opposition thing,
uh,
in a city called Hama by killing 20,000
people and like bombing the fuck out of
the city and it,
it put it,
put it down.
And I think that perhaps in his mind he
thought that he could do the same when
there was an uprising against him.
But obviously that wasn't what happened.
Well that's um,
I mean that's a story of Saddam Hussein
and his sons as well.
I imagine being the son of a,
an evil,
brutal dictator.
Yeah.
And you're just like,
well,
those sons was ended up like these
fucking nero figures.
Don't say it.
I mean,
it's like the father is very often like
a thuggish military guy and then the sun
is this a princeling who always got
whatever he wanted in his life and
that's when it gets so,
so weird.
You see
with like Kim Jong Il also.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And Uday and Qusay is,
I would assume,
yeah,
those motherfuckers who,
God or it's more horrible stories about
what they would do.
They would find women that were getting
married and they would take them from
their husband,
rape them,
and then feed them to dogs.
They had dogs that they had in their
basement that they just didn't feed.
And they would throw people that they
didn't like to their dogs and the dogs
are Tam apart.
Whoa.
And then they would watch of course.
But the,
the,
the fact that a person can get to that
place,
that a person can get to that place
where they eat w in the weirdest way.
We're flexible in a beautiful way.
You know,
when you can see someone who can create
beautiful songs and art and they can
touch people with their words and their
thoughts and their deeds and you know,
they can,
they can be something inspirational and
amazing,
but we're also flexible in this horrific
way where they could play upon the worst
fears and the worst,
the worst emotions that people are
capable of manifesting.
And they could just just attack and
torture and maim and brutalized and
murdered and they could do it wantonly
and do it with no for no real reason.
They could do it sadistically for fun,
for recreation.
The fact that that that's the same beast
has just,
they're human beings and it's like,
I mean there could obviously be some
anomalies in the brain itself,
but essentially a good portion of what
makes a person who they are is their
environment and their life experiences
and the nurturing and like how they were
raised and what they're exposed to.
And we get,
we're so flexible and pliable because we
want to survive that we're capable the
same species during the same time
period.
We're not talking about like cave people
that cannibalize because they didn't
have books than it and understand it was
bad and they had invented language yet
over talking about people with the
Internet,
they're capable of doing these horrific
things,
but at the same time there's someone
like,
you know what I mean?
You fill in the blank.
There's a lot of beautiful people out
there that do things,
but my friend Justin wren was um,
from these photos over here who goes to
the Congo and he lives with the pygmies
for six months a year and he,
he need builds wells for them and he
gets malaria and almost dies and you
know,
he's an American from Texas.
He just went over there and saw how
incredible these people were and he
dedicates his life to it.
He's like,
to me,
he's like one of my favorite people
because he's just like this beautiful
manifestation of like experiencing like
friendship and love from these people.
Then just becoming incredibly dedicated
to try to take care of them.
But these people exist at the same time.
It's just,
it's so hard to understand like a parent
is a fucking parrot.
You know,
some parents you can tame and they'll
eat peanuts out of your hand and other
ones they live in the trees,
but they're fucking parrots and were
like everything all at once.
We're so,
we're so weird or so weird,
you know?
I mean I'm a fan of people,
don't get me wrong,
but here you're pro people.
I'm a huge fan of people.
I love people.
I think we're amazing but we're also
horrible.
You know,
it's,
it's what we're capable of is so strict
cause like,
you know,
like you or I are not capable of those
things.
So for us to see that,
like what we consider a horrible person
in America,
it's like someone who's says something
horrible on,
you know,
on twitter about race or something like
that or someone who's a,
you know,
disparaging about President Obama or you
know,
it's like,
it's so minor and a lot of ways what we
shame people for here,
you know,
he didn't use the correct gender pronoun
you piece of Shit.
You know,
meanwhile there's terrible,
terrible things that are going on at the
same part of the world in the same time
in other parts of the world.
I mean,
I,
I don't believe in our race to the
bottom.
It shouldn't be like,
well,
you haven't like thrown someone to the
dog,
so you're cool,
you know?
No,
but I,
I definitely,
I,
I definitely hear where you're coming
from.
Hm.
That is funny,
right?
You can always look at like Saddam
Hussein's kids and I'm like,
I'm fine.
Feel like all I did was punch a baby.
I did not dog shamed me if my dad
punching,
shaming sharing's a new thing.
Right.
When did shaming come around?
I mean,
public shaming,
like the term
public shaming is sort of an old
American tradition.
We have a book called the scarlet letter
about public shaming.
Yeah.
But not as a phrase,
you know,
like fat shaming,
you know what you mean when it,
when it became,
um,
slut shaming.
Like these terms are very new.
These are like,
these are like this new concepts.
I mean,
I think that they're their new corn.
Just to describe,
to describe,
um,
you know,
old behavior.
The truth is I do think people should be
criticized for like,
I dunno,
I feel like if you're going on twitter
and you're writing,
you're a dumb whore to random women.
Like that is jerk ass behavior and
people should tell you that you're being
a fucking jerk for it.
And she's really into it.
That's her thing.
She's previously expressed days.
She says previously expressed a desire
for that.
Yeah.
They have like an established
relationship.
You're a dumb whore.
Oh,
you fucker get over here.
Like,
yeah,
no creek previous consent,
but here's rent to random random women
who don't have that in their twitter
bio.
That that's what they're into.
I think like you were being a jerk ass.
I'm someone who's like,
fuck you.
Stop calling random women whores on
twitter.
Oh yeah.
I think that,
I think that's fine.
That what we were talking about before
about having no,
um,
that one day we're going to come a time
where there's no boundaries between
people.
I'm really absolutely convinced this.
Like,
I've,
uh,
I've had these weird,
um,
trips in a sensory deprivation tank
where I've sort of seen this take place,
the slow acceptance of what is the
ultimate inevitable reality.
And it kind of freaks me out sometimes I
have to get out of the tank cause I just
can't handle it because I really,
I think like life as a person,
we have this idea that we're gonna put
our shell on and we're good.
I've got Michelle on,
this is going to be no shells.
It's,
it's,
we're gonna just have to somehow or
another like,
you know how you have friends?
Like I have friends that,
uh,
I'm almost too close to them.
I know everything they do.
You know,
like,
what'd you do?
Ah,
you fuck her?
Why'd you do that?
Oh my God,
what are you doing?
I just fucking lost my mind.
And,
but you know,
everything like we're going to know that
about everybody.
It's just a matter of time.
But the thing is I don't think it's
going to make us nicer to each other and
make us like each other better.
I think that one of the things that
twitter has done,
I mean,
I love twitter,
like I'm addicted to twitter.
I love it.
I think it's really cool.
But in addition to having a speak to all
sorts of amazing people that we never
would have spoken to before,
it also like really revealed what other
people were thinking and made us like
really dislike them for it to knit a lot
of ways.
Right?
Yeah.
Well it's also the anonymity,
the ability to reach out to molly and
just say some mean shit anonymously.
You know,
you're just this little egg.
I'm a little egg,
you know,
that's all your,
your icon is.
And you know,
you have been a series of letters to
represent your egg and then you're like,
fuck you molly crab asshole.
You fucking bitch already your bull
shit.
I mean,
I believe that's how it went down.
I think you're a fucking attention
whore.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then you read that,
you're like,
oh,
you know,
you've fucking anonymous person is
searing my soul with your hate
mean.
I don't like.
I get a lot of like as a,
as I'm sure you do.
I think.
Okay,
so this is the thing.
Sometimes the thing that helps him put
it in perspective is I got 70,000
twitter followers and I think if I ever
had any other grouping,
like any real life grouping of 70,000
people,
like what would be the jackass ratio
that I would expect in that
it's always one in 100 that's my
thought.
My thought is it's one,
it's the real 1% we should be concerned
with the jackass 1% the mean people.
Yeah,
because I think they're,
they're so,
they're so calm.
Like the idea of the 1% being like the
real problem in America being successful
people.
I think if you've got the 1% of all the
successful people together,
only 1% of them would be evil cunts.
I really believe that.
I think 1% of Pr,
I think you keep going with the 1% like
how many of those will add of those
people that are evil,
how many of them are true sociopath?
Probably ones percent of them too.
I was like,
he keeps going.
But if you have 300 million people,
you're dealing with 3 million assholes.
Like if there's a hundred people,
one of them is going to suck.
And if you have 300 million,
you have 3 million people that suck.
And if they all get ahold of your
twitter account,
you're going to think the world has
ended.
You're going to think my God and you
won't see the other 99.
You won't see them because the hateful
words of the one will just be
overwhelming.
And every now and then molly,
your book's amazing collection.
Yeah,
you'll,
you'll try to find it.
I mean,
I've watched people in scale,
like I had,
like we were talking about Lance
Armstrong and I looked at the mentions
that Lance Armstrong gets on twitter.
Like anything he writes and like
anything he wrote like had a great time,
you know,
uh,
doing these,
this race was as good at times when
you're running away from drug tests,
like sake,
I think they can't help it.
It's like they,
people just love to dig.
They just love to fucking reach out of
that rib cage,
pull out your heart.
Ah,
they can't help it.
They know they can.
And it's also a new ability that human
beings have sort of cultivated over the
last couple of decades really didn't
exist before.
Well,
before,
like you would had to have like written
on
letter left your mom's basement,
walked all the way down to the block.
Humans basement.
Why don't I say like Your Dad's base and
your girlfriend's based and there's so
many other basements these people could
be in.
Like why do I have to put them all in
their mom's basement?
Because it's somehow or another for a
man,
the most pathetic thing.
Like,
mom,
I'm done here.
Mom.
Stop yelling.
I'm down.
You're telling people they're wrong on
the internet.
You're typing up a fucking stone.
We're trying to hurt land,
shine,
kneeling,
cycling,
lying.
Yeah.
I like,
I liked that.
That was,
that was a,
that was a good,
uh,
good personification of that.
It's like this feeling of just wanting
to just somehow or another get a
reaction and it's all losers.
That's unfortunate.
I mean,
I hate to say that to those people,
right?
They're like,
no,
I'm a,
I'm a winner.
And I think he just,
what he did was dishonorable.
Okay,
well then you might think it,
but if you actually are sitting around
trying to attack him,
I guarantee you that his energy and
focus that you could have best spent on
your own life 100%
or like maybe if you're just like,
I mean critical person who is a winner,
you could have written a really great
essay about like juicing in the sport
that like really took him down and then,
yeah,
and then you have challenged,
you're like meaning this in a positive
and winning direction.
But if you really looked at the essay,
honestly,
you'd have to take down the whole sport
itself.
You mean you really wouldn't.
Who if you want to take down Lance
Armstrong,
you'd have to take them down by his
individual acts actions in defending his
actions in the sport.
Yeah.
That,
that's,
he admits that he,
he's pretty open about the fact that he
fucked up and then he made some pretty
horrible choices.
Does it though the sport itself,
like if you really wanted to write an
essay,
you'd write what the fuck you bunch of
steroid using bike riders.
That's what you got.
Yeah.
And you'd write like properly about the
economic impetus and how all the ways
that like top people were able to kind
of condone it but then get out with
their hands clean and you'd write
something like that really channeled
your meaning this into a positive
direction that really tore shit.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing about blogs too
though.
There's a lot of pee.
I've,
I've read some really mean blogs.
People write about folks and I'm like,
what's interesting about this is like
blogs or not a conversation.
It's like you're,
you have this,
uh,
attack,
this focused attack of,
of an individual.
But if that individual was there and
they could respond to this and you could
have a communicate,
it would be a different thing.
Like what it is is like,
uh,
it's like a,
a message tied to the Clav,
a raven that you're sending out.
Like it's,
there's,
so it's such a one way thing.
It's,
it's not,
it's not really an effective way to
communicate cause you're not really
trying to communicate.
We tried to do is hurt somebody.
Like when you see attack blogs,
I mean they're the worst.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's some that deserve it.
Like if you could write an an expo,
say on someone who runs some horrible
business that is using slave labor or
fill in the blank on some terrible
scenario that you could expose.
Yeah,
I mean the,
the,
the world should see it like,
okay here Matt,
Tie Ebs Expos,
a's on the financial collapse.
Brilliant,
perfect.
And you know that those are real,
legitimate and important.
But I've read some things that people
written,
they're just about like random
celebrities or you know,
like
you're just like why?
Why are you that invested in tyler
swift?
Like how do you have so much opinion
then it's Taylor.
Fuck,
I'm not fucking Dork.
I don't know anything.
Well I'm a fucking Dork to haters.
Gonna hate,
hate,
hate that fucking song.
I liked that song,
goddammit.
Cause I have daughters and I have a wife
that God damn songs playing all the
time.
They play in the car.
When I'm with them,
I'm like,
that's okay,
you can play that one.
I liked that one.
Cool.
That's awesome.
Sudden I'm embarrassed that I like it.
It shows like diverse musical tastes.
That's all right.
Definitely have that.
Sometimes too diverse,
you know.
But um,
I dunno how we got onto that,
but it's like,
yeah,
like mean takedowns of like a some
singer like come on really is this
terrible person really affecting your
life in some strange way.
But the like the comments that people
will make to people,
I believe on twitter and facebook,
all these,
and not facebook,
it's like slightly less anonymous,
but all these anonymous methods of
communicating,
they're gonna dissolve slowly but surely
the boundaries between people.
It's not just going to be the NSA that
can find out exactly what you're doing
and who's saying what to who.
It's going to be the whole fucking
world.
Everyone's going to be able to do that
and it's going to be very,
very weird.
Very weird.
The other thing is like,
people,
we'll find out the people who are doing
that.
I remember there was this like asshole
who made a bunch of twitter accounts to
um,
right that women who worked in tech but
then just brand and women,
he didn't like cunts and he really
fixated on this one woman who is a
programmer at Tor,
which is an anonymous web browser.
And he like made seven twitter accounts
at one point until I tell her she was a
cunt.
And so finally she was like,
she was like this,
this has gone on long enough.
And um,
when he was visiting her website,
presumably to find more proof that she
was a [inaudible],
she got his Ip address track down where
he worked in,
posted his name and his workplace.
And with the line that was like his
classic,
she wrote should have used tour
foucault.
I was like,
you know,
if you went up to a bunch of bunch of
women or if you went on to a bunch of
women at bars and just screamed like
cunt in their face,
like eventually either them or their
boyfriend or someone around is going to
hit you.
But because were doing this online
you thought like,
wow,
I can just go up to people and scream
content.
Nothing's ever going to happen.
And some,
you know it did.
And there's no one's going to be
sympathetic to anyone's going to get
seven twitter accounts just to call some
woman a con.
Yeah.
No,
no one feels bad that he got hit that he
got dogs were guy got talks.
Well he was just expressing himself and
exercising his first amendment rights.
No,
I think um,
I really think we're,
we're maybe a few years away from that
just not being around anymore from it
being some strange new world or we're
all going to know exactly.
I think I re I really believe that it's,
we're maybe 10 years away from being
able to reach those thoughts.
Oh God.
Can you imagine?
Yeah.
It's going to be very strange.
Let's get the,
all the romance and thinks is going to
be gone because so much of like so much
of like really exciting things in life
is like anticipating and not knowing.
And then,
you know,
it's almost like the unwrapping of
Christmas presents like,
well,
like when someone texts you,
Hey,
what are you doing?
And you're like,
yes,
it's her book.
You know,
like there's that,
that moment where you didn't know
someone likes you or not like what's
going on?
And then you're going back and forth
with each other is sending each other
emails or you get that phone call out of
the blue from someone he didn't know.
They really were in the you and you're
like,
yeah,
but when you know everyone's thoughts,
it's going to be like all the Rome,
ah,
your enemy.
You fucker.
Why?
Why are you playing?
There's going to be no playing cool.
There's going to be no,
you know that all the,
you know,
you're,
when you go to apply for a job,
you're like,
well,
you fucking unlike me so I'll just get
out of here.
You think I'm a loser so you're not
going to hire me.
This is not going to mean the illusions.
So although a lot of romance going to be
gone a lot,
a lot of the fun of things is not
knowing.
You know,
we don't like that though.
No,
I'm an,
I'm an artist.
I,
I I like,
I like the not knowing.
I like the mystery.
Sometimes
it's fine as long as it works out.
Obviously it's worked out for you.
You're a young woman,
you're already,
you already have a book published.
You have many,
many,
many art pieces published.
If journalism things that you've done.
I was like,
it's worked out for you and all this
romance,
but for some people that's not happening
for them and they're like,
God dammit.
I just think it would be better if there
was no secrets.
But if you're that person and it wasn't
working out for you,
probably if there are no secrets,
you would just have the crushing
disappointment of realizing either no
one was thinking of you or they're
thinking bad things about you when it
would just make you more unhappy maybe.
But is what we are as human beings
currently.
Is that a static state and is this a
state that we can expect to exist in,
in sort of this form speaking with our
mouths,
making noises with our faces,
interpretating it,
interpreting it in our own minds and,
and listening to other people say things
and sort of establishing what their
meaning is that it is that does this is
going to be forever.
This is going to be how he went.
No,
no fucking way.
Just like a monkey climbed off of a tree
and you know,
and eventually became a person 200 plus
thousand years later or whatever the
fuck it was.
Whatever has led us to improve,
to become what we are today is a
continuous cycle.
It's not going to stop.
And I think that this idea that what
we've got right now like,
oh this,
the romance of not knowing and you know,
it's amazing and it all works out well.
It's fucking,
it's temporary.
This is a little,
when we look back in time to the amount
of time that we've spent in this state,
currently the Internet state,
it's been so brief but so transcendent.
Okay.
Absolutely.
It like the most transcendent thing.
I mean I think as much or more than like
the printing press probably more my God,
one of the like really good articles I
was reading about the refugee stuff is
by the Iraqi journalists that I always
plug cause he's so brilliant.
Plays up dual a hud and he did this
piece about,
you know,
people making the trip and one of the
things he talked about is that this was
a trip that when he was a young man in
Iraq,
he had tried to pay a smuggler to do and
the smuggler like defrauded him and he
didn't get to do it but it was all under
the control of smugglers.
Whereas now if you have a cell phone,
like once you get from Turkey to Greece,
once you do that little four hour boat
ride,
he just put on the gps maps on your cell
phone and you walk,
wow,
you don't need smugglers after that.
Isn't that crazy?
It completely up ended the end to this
entire like really like disgusting,
nasty business.
Well similar in a lot of ways to the
business of sneaking people over from
Mexico.
You know,
I have a friend who has been living in
America for
more than 20 years because I've known
him for,
I've known him for 18 years.
So He's,
I think he's been living in America for
like 27,
28 years.
And that's how he came over.
I came over in a fucking van in the
middle of the night and they got out and
there was a guy behind them that had a,
a stick,
like,
uh,
they,
they would take like a giant,
like branch from a tree with all the
leaves.
And as they walked,
one guy behind them would waive the
branch back and forth to cover up their
footsteps.
Yeah,
yeah.
And they did it through the middle of
the night.
And,
um,
they eventually got to some sort of
border town where there was an Arizona
or whatever and uh,
they made their way and infiltrated into
cities and eventually found jobs and
barely survived,
barely fed themselves.
And Fuck,
man,
he just imagined that life.
And then there's all these people we've
got to tighten up our borders.
Fuck man.
Like that,
that's high enough that the borders
shut.
I mean,
trump's like idiot idea of that wall.
It's not even like physically possible
to build,
cause we'd have to go through all these
like rivers and take over people's land
and his like,
how did we get presidential candidates
who,
not that they're stupid,
not they're crazy,
but who like fundamentally denied
physical reality.
Like this is what,
this is where we are right now.
We,
yeah,
I don't think he
necessarily as a presidential candidate,
I don't buy it.
You think you think it's to the other
ones look moderate
and reasonable?
No,
I don't think it's,
um,
some grand conspiracy.
I think it's him riding this crazy wave
of attention and trying to think in his
own mind that it's justified because
he's shining light on these important
issues in a way that only he can because
he's independently wealthy and he's not
bound to,
you know,
the,
um,
the wishes of his constituents.
He can just kind of go out there and
say,
I want to put a giant wall up and call
it the trump wall and then we're going
to keep off the Mexicans.
Yeah.
And meanwhile,
everybody wants to fucking kill him and
in his face as fallen off his bones.
It's just,
it's so bizarre.
It's so cohen brothers ask that like,
he really does seem like satire.
I mean,
he's like the ultimate American satire
president candidate.
Did you ever interview him like back
before,
right?
No,
no,
I've never met him.
Nothing.
I,
uh,
once I confronted him at a press
conference in Dubai,
it's like one of my finest moments.
I know.
I was really scared because Dubai is a,
it's please state,
you know,
there's no free speech there.
It's real,
real,
you know,
they'll lock you up and they're rich
enough.
They don't really care about your
American passport that much.
And so as that,
this press conference where he had these
golf courses that he was licensing his
name too,
and I had some Intel that the guys that
were building the golf courses were
getting 200 bucks a month to do
construction work.
And like the Emirates,
the average salary of an Mrr adi is,
I think it's like sixty thousand sixty
thousand a year I think.
And he's gets 200 a month,
you know,
to do like hard ass construction work.
And so I get up during the press
conference where he's getting his ass
kissed and I'm waving my hand around and
I say,
you know Mr. Trump,
you've been saying how you know this all
stands for luxury and your construction
guys are getting $200 a month.
Are You satisfied with that?
And his mouth fucking shriveled.
I've never seen it like shriveled,
this little tiny Rosebud at hate.
And I got so yelled at,
but he yelled at you.
He didn't yell at me that the,
the underling yelled at me.
He's under the underlying from the MRI
pr firm that was there.
What did they say?
That's not an appropriate question.
How's that?
Not Appropriate.
I know.
And then the next question was,
Mr. Trump,
you stand for luxury in Dubai stands for
luxury.
Is that why you do buy like each other?
Some tough,
tough stuff.
So did he answer you?
No,
he didn't.
He didn't answer me.
He just like mouth trivial and like
Ivanka his mouth when all small like
everyone's mouth went really small with
anger.
Cos this is a long time ago,
right?
Is that the drawing?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the drawing and man,
ah,
he was so angry at me cause I,
cause I took like a little startup to
just picture of him.
But yeah,
he was like,
they're talking about how New York
should be more like Dubai because in
Dubai everything was perfect.
Yeah.
He,
he liked the ass kissing.
He said that he built the greatest
architectural buildings in New York.
I beg to differ.
Yeah.
Wow.
He really said that.
You know,
my friend Joey Diaz grew up in New York
and he said,
one of the things that people forget
about Donald Trump is all the disputes
that he had with small local
construction that used,
they use for projects.
And now these people like wound up going
out of business and they,
you know,
they couldn't,
they couldn't battle him financially.
And like,
he's like this wave of people that hate
him in that whole construction business.
I don't know who's right and who's wrong
about those disputes,
but the idea that you could take that
model,
which is already problematic in America
and then take it and wrap it up in a
giant way and do buy that fucking piece
that vice did on those people that are
in Dubai that are trapped where they
take their passports.
I think that,
I think I did a big piece on that.
Did you?
Yeah,
there was a,
um,
how long ago was your amendment?
No,
this was a few years ago.
Like maybe six or seven years ago.
There was a,
um,
a camp that they went to and these men
were crow,
just openly weeping.
There was showing this like hole in the
ground where they have to shit.
And they were showing how poor the water
is and they had promised them a
substantial amount of money per month
and they were coming over from India and
the Philippines,
a lot of third world countries.
And once they got there they would take
their passports away and then reduce
their salary traumatically,
you know,
and they couldn't leave and they were
forcing them to build these structures.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's totally like that.
And then the other really fucked up
thing is that like these guys,
they're not passive.
Like they try to strike and stuff,
especially very often.
Not only do they reduce their salaries,
they just don't pay him.
Like,
and can you imagine like you've like a
wife and kids at home,
you know,
who are like depending on you to like go
to another country and you know,
make,
make money for the family and then you
just don't get paid for three months.
Like,
it's like,
you know,
breaking a whole family.
And so these guys will do strikes,
they'll do sit downs in front of the
buses and then they hold them off to
jail and deport them when they do that.
And it's,
it's scary.
It's so scary that it's again,
what we're talking about,
the spectrum of human behavior that,
I mean it's like a few steps away from
being a serial killer,
but it's just this s s sort of
pathological detachment from compassion.
You know,
that you don't,
you don't care about these people that
are risking their lives to make these
giant buildings that are,
these royal people are gonna walk on
roses and they throw at their feet and
step into these things and go skiing in
the middle of summer.
And these gigantic buildings they make,
they make these crazy fucking structures
over there cause they,
they almost have an unlimited budget.
It's almost like they have like an idea
in their head,
you know,
I would like to fly in doors and they're
like,
okay,
we're going to build you a mile high
fucking gigantic building where you
could fly inside.
And you know,
and then you have planes that you could
fly indoors.
Like I shouldn't even have said that
because someone in Dubai is probably
listening and a light bulb went off in
their head yes and indoor flight course.
And it's what's so strange is like I was
prepared to like hate Dubai.
How Dubai look like.
I hate how Dubai is,
but I mean I was prepared to like
aesthetically hated as well as ethically
hated.
But what's weird is when you go there,
it's beautiful.
That's the thing.
It's like,
I remember I was looking at that
building like the Shard,
you know the worlds,
the worlds tallest building Alberg did
you go in it?
Um,
I went down to the ground floor and I
bought a $20 cup of coffee.
$20 is $20.
Oh my God.
How it taste like a fucking cup of iced
coffee.
We have a day.
Was that was just sort of a bevel an
object.
But so I was like going into,
I was going into it like prepared to
like really like aesthetically judge it
too.
And like the thing is it's like so
beautiful.
And then I was remembering,
I was like for cy is also beautiful and
look at how that was made and it was
this weird thing cause you,
you think about how splendors always
made and how like the most beautiful
things in the world,
you know,
always are constructed and you
definitely go there and you're like,
this is the city of the future and this
is the new aristocrats and this is
beautiful and it's all being built by
slaves who are dying to build it.
Well I dunno if it's the future with
stuff in the future of that area,
but they just have this strange world
where it was incredibly poor up until
just a few decades ago and then all of a
sudden they start pumping oil out of
that place and the money is astronomical
and the change in the amount of money
that area has,
the few that have it,
the,
the disparity of wealth is just
unimaginable.
One of the kinds of interesting things
that they did in Abu Dhabi,
which actually I kind of,
I admire it,
is that in a lot of countries when they
get oil money,
like someone steals it,
you know,
up top.
But in Abu Dhabi what they did was they
gave citizens a lot of entitlements to
stuff.
Like you get free education.
If you're in a Morati,
you get a free healthcare housing,
get a stipend,
a Mrit.
Women are like super,
super educated.
Most,
uh,
most of the phds are Mrid women.
So like,
that's awesome.
But the thing is,
the flip side of that is like citizens
are only 10% of the population and it's
like 90,
90% of the people,
the people who do everything,
like the engineers,
the shop,
the shop workers,
the maids,
the,
um,
you know,
construction dudes like the people who
do every manner of work are not citizens
and have no rights to anything.
Wow.
That's a trip.
We're,
you know,
we're looking on the outside at that
place.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've talked to people that I've been,
I've been to Dubai and I've been to Abu
Dhabi,
I was there for a UFC event.
And uh,
you know,
without getting into anything political,
it's beautiful,
you know,
and you're like,
wow,
these are,
these people have done a great job and
constructing these things.
But the guy,
the guys that I was with,
um,
some of them went to,
uh,
they went to Dubai because we have the
night off and I was tired so I to stay
home,
if they went to Dubai,
the guy,
we're going to go to a bar.
And you know how it just,
some places you can go to drink,
like you have to drink in certain play
because it's illegal to have alcohol,
but there's some sort of weird loophole
and they said it was all Russian
prostitutes.
They said it was just like these
predatory coyote women that had crossed
over.
I would just like looking to dig just a
pocket cash from banging all these rich
dudes.
And I was like,
whoa.
Like I,
the,
my friend went to a bar and he said,
I'm not bullshitting.
This bar might've been 80% hookers and I
go,
that might,
he goes,
I never seen anything like it in my
life.
Yeah.
Women go over there to like,
it's make to make some serious money.
Bet You can.
I bet you can fucking clean it up.
But it's probably really dangerous too,
right.
You know,
I never did.
I never really did research on like sex
work in Dubai.
Like my,
and I'm like,
I'll be like,
I know mostly about construction work in
something about the maids and not so
much,
but I think for anyone who's not a
citizen,
it's dangerous because you like don't
have any real rights if you're not a
citizen.
Yeah.
I remember,
I think it was a British couple that
were making out on the beach and they
were arrested.
They were just kissing.
They were just,
but they were openly showing affection
on the beach and they were thrown in
jail.
I'm like,
whoa.
Wow.
This is another one.
This is the craziest one.
There was a British man who,
um,
he had eaten a poppy seed Bagel and
poppy seeds will,
you will test positive for heroin if you
eat,
like it's trace amounts,
but obviously it's not enough to be
psychoactive,
but it's enough to show up in a really
comprehensive blood examination.
So they tested this guy and uh,
he tested positive for heroin and they
put him in a fucking cell.
They're like,
he had a poppy seed Bagel at Heathrow
airport and that big old got him locked
up in a jail cell.
Like,
whoa.
There's another woman who was an
executive at Brillstein Gray,
which is a very prominent Los Angeles
Entertainment Group.
And,
uh,
she had,
um,
what does that shit that people take?
It's a,
it's a natural thing.
Oh,
I'm you take it when you want to go to
bed.
Uh,
no,
no.
It wasn't that it was a Melatonin.
Should Melatonin fucking Melatonin.
Yes.
You can't have Melatonin.
They arrested her,
locked her up,
took her passport,
put her in a jail cell for fucking
Melatonin and then you know,
somehow or another somehow got word of
it and they got her out eventually.
But what a terrifying moment it must
have been for her.
There was another guy who had a
marijuana seed like,
or a stem or a piece of marijuana that
was wedged in between the tread of his
shoes.
That was it.
And that was enough to put him in jail
and he was going to be sentenced for
some fucking astronomical amount of
time.
And I don't know what happened to that
poor guy,
but unfortunately for him,
he was a black guy with dreadlocks from
England and they were like,
ah,
dude.
Forever cage forever.
Yeah,
it's a really,
really,
really racist.
Some of them are here.
We'll go right here.
Some of the horror stories would be
reported by the BBC four year jail term
for possession of 0.003 grams of
cannabis stuck to the bottom of his
shoe.
That's the guy that's Keith Brown.
Robert Dalton on trial for alleged
possession of 0.3 grams of cannabis,
0.03 unnamed 20 year old on trial for
allegedly zaw cannabis.
Mostly.
I had this one dude I met there,
he's,
he's on the rowdy and he was really
interesting.
His name is Allen Edmonds store and he,
I mean like he's so brave,
right.
Cause you have so many privileges like
as an Mri especially came from like a
good family and everything,
you know,
you can really just coast it if you're
Mrd and your,
you know,
from a well off family.
And he made a web forum that let people
um,
discuss,
uh,
basically discuss the royal family
frankly.
And it also,
it let people discuss religion kind of
frankly.
And if you were an atheist,
you can talk about it on the web forum
and they fucking,
they locked him up for was hinge Elford
I have to have to check this but I want
to say was around nine months and then
factored in with scabies when he was in
jail and then when they let him out
affected and purposely,
yeah,
that's what he said.
He said that they like gave him a
blanket that had scabies on it.
And then when he was out the,
he had the series of unfortunate events
that happened up over $100,000
accidentally disappeared from his bank
account and no one knows how it got,
how I got missing.
And then like on two occasions at guys
just sort of jumped out and beat the
shit out of him and no one knows who
they were.
You know,
it's a mystery and his car just gets
stolen all the time.
And the tires keep getting error taken
out of it.
And you know,
magical mystery.
No one knows who's behind that.
Uh Huh.
Fuck yeah.
Could you imagine if you like pissed off
some royal family and they just hired
some dude and they pay him and your job
is to fuck with this guy forever.
Like that's it.
That's your job.
Or you know,
if you're like some sort of a rich
billionaire character,
you could hire a bunch of people and you
could have a whole team,
you know,
and their,
their jobs just to fuck with people.
There's this one guy,
I don't like them.
Let's go get them.
I mean,
that wouldn't be hard.
Like if you're like some trump guy and
you've got billions of dollars and
someone like molly crab,
apple makes you feel like shit at some
Dubai press event and you're like,
fuck this bitch.
This is what we're going to do.
I'm going to hire a team and I'm going
to fuck with molly crab apples life.
I mean that's a reality.
Like someone who's not wealthy,
they could do something like that.
That's scary shit.
Yeah,
they definitely,
they definitely could know they could
hire somebody.
Just every time he got to your car,
your tires are flat.
Like what the fuck?
Tacos.
At a certain point though,
you'd probably put up like a little cam
on your car and you know,
or you'd hire some people to,
yeah,
exactly.
It'd be like war of the proxies,
war
proxies.
That's it,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know what,
or have you gone to any places that were
positive in your journalism escapades?
I love Istanbul.
Istanbul is like one of my favorite
cities ever.
It's just so gorgeous.
And it's so exciting.
And you walked down like Easter collage
I,
Jesse,
which is,
um,
sort of the main street in a
neighborhood called Bay Olu and it's
like,
there's like lights and all these
couples hand in hand and everyone's
playing music.
There's like kids selling flower crowns.
It's just like,
it feels like the sort of boulevard that
every other boulevard in the world is
trying to be.
It's so magic.
And I mean,
I could,
I could just walk around Istanbul like
anytime of day or night and I would
never not like have my heartbeat faster
that city.
Wow.
So that's your favorite spot?
That's my favorite spot.
You'd ever be an ex.
Pat moved to Istanbul and they're
arresting a lot of that.
They have a bad record unfortunately for
arresting journalists.
They are one of the,
uh,
one of my colleagues.
Yeah.
One of my colleagues' advice,
uh,
this,
um,
brilliant,
uh,
Kurdish dude,
um,
Mohammed Rasulullah,
he is like currently in jail right now
for doing journalism and Turkey and
vices.
Like you're trying really hard to get
him out,
but he is like rotting in a jail cell
and they claim that he is isis because
he used it in cryption.
He is a Kurdish dude.
He's a Kurdish dude that like covers all
of the anti isis stuff.
He's not,
he's not isis.
This is so embarrassing and a name and
yeah,
he's,
he's routing in a jail cell there.
How long has he been there?
Oh God,
it's over.
I think it's going to be going on three
months now.
And they,
I don't think they've even really
charged them yet.
They're just like leaked statements to
the press.
Wow.
But,
um,
that,
that aside,
I,
you know,
the,
the political repression aside,
I really do find it assembled,
be marvelous city.
No place is perfect.
They charged him with,
so what is his actual w what is their
grievance with them?
What does the actual issue,
he was going with these two British vice
journalists and they were covering a
clashes between the Turkish government
and Kurds in the south and they pick
them up doing that.
So they just decided they didn't like
him.
[inaudible] he's doing Carl's in
trouble.
Well they,
they've been actually like deporting and
fucking with a lot of journalists who
have been doing this.
But I think,
I think it's like they,
the two British guys got out cause you
know they're British.
Whereas if you're in a rocky Kurd like
no,
but who's going to,
who's going to be the person putting
pressure on Turkey for you?
I'm sure you're aware of that Saudi
Arabian blogger that's been beaten
repeatedly there.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's a fucking horrible story too.
That's one of the weirdest aspects of
the United States.
A relationship with Saudi Arabia.
It's like we'll talk about all the
atrocities that are committed by all
these different countries,
but Saudi Arabia is
moderate and meanwhile they like sent,
they sentenced a poet to death for
poetry in Saudi recently.
How bad was the poetry though?
Was it like def jam slam comedy in the
little things?
All right.
Why are you poetry shaming?
Why are you,
why are you have what you have to free
verse shame right now,
you know?
No,
it's a phrase in reverse.
When you make culture that doesn't like
Reimer or how did he meet her or
anything?
No,
Haikus a short one.
Right.
I'm not much into poetry,
but I remember I,
I've gone to,
I went to a poetry slam in Venice once,
which is the perfect place to go because
people take themselves so fucking
seriously.
And that was with a buddy of mine and we
were a high
as you should ever be,
what you were in public walking around
talking to people like barely aware of
reality.
And we walked by this place and it was a
poetry slam and we ha,
I'm like,
we have to go inside.
We have to go inside.
And we went inside and we were both like
biting her hands.
Try not to laugh because it was just so
for po preposterous,
just so you know,
that really just pretentious save the
world type
true.
20 year old white guys with dreadlocks.
Yeah.
I,
I do.
I mean,
I think as a visual artist I have a
similar thing when I see like really,
really bad art work and I'm just like,
not only are you shaming yourself,
you're shaming my whole profession here.
Yeah.
But you know what I also like as I've
gotten older and I've sort of understand
the nuance of life,
like what this guy's doing,
this is stupid shame,
shamp slam,
whatever poetry.
What he really is doing is she's trying
to express himself and he's developing
as a person and right now it's kind of
ridiculous to other people that are
maybe a little bit more well versed in
the ways of the world and with a more
social experience.
What he's trying to do is like,
he sees the world is wrong and he wants
to get Social Brownie points by pointing
it out and you know,
and people clap and cheer and he's so,
he sat down this loose leaf binder and
wrote all this stuff out and he's just
feels like he's really good.
And one day he'll look back at that and
go,
what a fucking moron.
I was just like,
I'll look back at,
I have a comedy notebook from 1990 and I
should probably burn it in case someone
breaks in my house and finds it.
Dude.
Like if you die then someone will
publish the collected papers of Joe
Rogan and this will be your most famous
thing,
a bit in there about wonder woman,
like trying to explain wonder woman.
It's so bad,
but I was,
you know,
21 years old or whatever the fuck I was
at the time.
It's like,
it's just,
that's what you're,
you're when you suck then one of your
yacht,
I mean it takes a while to get good at
anything.
Many years I,
sometimes I look back at my old drawings
and I'm like,
how did I ever get hired as an artist?
What delusional process did I ever think
that I'd be an artist putting these
things out there and again and again and
again in the face of very deserted
projection for many years.
But it worked out right?
Because like if you just keep chipping
away at it and eventually eventually get
through.
And I really,
I tried to actually really write about
that in my book because I feel like
sometimes a lot of artists they front
and they act like,
oh,
I was just really good from the start
and then it was really easy and I was
like,
no,
I sucked from the start.
And it was really hard.
Yeah.
Most comedians will tell you that they
suck from the start except the ones that
are aren't that good,
which will claim that they were always
awesome was the ones,
I think all my friends that are,
that are really good,
they'll all tell you they're fucking
newer were terrible.
I have um,
two young daughters and one of the cool
things is watching their art.
Like they're really in the art,
especially my seven year old is really
into it.
She draws every day.
It's so cool.
And,
um,
W W I watch her early stuff like I save
all our and,
or at least representations like,
you know,
like some of it and watching like there
early like control of her motor skills
in our hands from the time she was like
three to four years later.
This just dramatic difference in what
she's ability,
you know,
her ability to draw things and draw
representations and figure out like
perspective and sizes.
And we were going through this book
yesterday,
she has this um,
how to draw a figures book and it was
the weirdest fucking thing because um,
it was these princesses,
it's just trying to draw princesses and
um,
I'm,
I'm looking at the book and we're going
through it together and you know,
it's like one of those books where you
have a framework,
you know,
like there's like balls and sticks and
you try to like make the framework and
then you had the close to the framework
and totally.
But the women's legs were like more than
twice as long as they should have been.
When you're trying to do those like
fashiony cartoon drawings,
everyone is like so stretched out and
that's what's weird is that you get so
used to seeing that,
that when you see like cartoon people
done it,
they're real proportions.
They all look like weird and stubby.
Yeah.
Well that's gotta be weird for it
because it doesn't seem that way for
men.
Like I was looking at the
representations of men,
they're fairly proportionate,
but with,
with women,
it was all these insanely long legs and
insanely skinny bodies.
And I was like,
this is fucking strange.
So much so that I had a pointed out to
her,
you know,
she's like,
uh,
you know,
she's drawing it.
I go,
well here's the deal.
You know,
I'm like,
this is,
you can draw it like this.
One of the beautiful things about art is
you can do whatever you want.
If you want to make people that have
giant hands that are size of those phone
number ones that people were at a
football game,
you could totally do that.
No one can stop you.
It's cause it's just drawing is your
expression.
Whatever you want to do,
but if you want to draw like a real
person.
And so then we started,
I started showing her like a real human
body.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to stand up and I'll stand up
next to the wall.
And what we're gonna do is we're going
to mark on the wall where the top of my
head is and where my waist is.
Awesome.
And so we went from the top of my head
to the waist and then we went from the
waist down to the feet and I said,
and you notice that like they're pretty
much the same or at least close,
but the women in these cartoon things
you're supposed to draw were no
bullshit.
There was twice as much length in their
legs as there was from your waist up to
their head.
And she was like,
well why do they do that?
And I go,
well thank some people think that it
looks better to make people that aren't
real,
that that are like longer than reality,
but like why do we accept that?
Because like if there was a woman and
that she had like,
like a normal proportion body but
enormous tits,
just freakish tits.
Like everybody would look at that and
go,
what the fuck are you making these kids
draw,
you know?
But for,
for whatever reason,
like having the,
and by the way,
some people have freakish tits.
There's,
there's people that for whatever reason
there's that,
that poor dude who can't go
to the airport without getting frisked
cause he has this giant Hog,
has like some 20 inch Dick.
I was like,
he's got the,
got the world's largest deck.
And like they,
they always check his pants to think
he's carrying drugs or something.
Well there's women out there that are
just naturally born with enormous
breasts and there's nothing they could
do about it.
There's no one born with knowing that
there's no one six feet tall and only
two feet of them are upper body and the
rest of it,
his legs,
that's just doesn't exist.
You know,
it's,
it's crazy.
And even when I was at art school,
we would have a different formula for
drying figures and there was like they
would measure it and head.
So it's like this figure is nine heads
and a fashion figure.
W W which what they called it,
which is,
you know,
that take her for a fashion illustration
was like so many more heads than like
any other figure.
And so it was like that crazy along the
unaided thing and exactly what you're
saying with like the crazy daddy long
legs,
legs.
It's very strange because for men we,
I've never talked to a man who
understands that look because men are
not attracted.
I mean I'm sure everybody varies,
right?
But most men are not attractive to these
stick figure people.
But women are expected to be stick
figure people to be models.
It's one of the weirdest things.
And then women think that in order to be
attractive,
they have to be like these media
representations of women.
So they have to starve themselves.
And then men are like,
no,
don't do that.
No one likes that.
But,
so like there's this weird disconnect
between what the opposite sex or,
I mean,
I don't know,
I can't speak for lesbians obviously,
but with the opposite sex finds
attractive and the representations of
attractive women like sucked in cheeks,
ba basically like on death's door,
like,
yeah,
she's hot.
Like,
no,
that's weird.
It's,
it's weird to see someone all cracked
out and skinny like that being the most
with the most obvious representation of
like a,
a beautiful person in Nice clothes.
I mean,
I think it's,
you know,
fashion models aren't for men,
or they're not first,
they're not for straight men.
They're supposed to appeal to women who
are buying the clothing.
But do they even,
I don't,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
fashion,
I think,
you know,
women of all sizes,
skinny,
whatever.
I think I'll be super beautiful as long
as that's really you.
Yeah.
As long as you're not harming yourself
to do it.
But,
um,
I think that,
I don't know,
I think the idea is that you can just
hang any clothing on them and it doesn't
affect the hang of the clothing.
So it's like almost like they're as
close to it being
like a coat hanger as possible.
I think that's the theoretical
underpinnings of it.
Um,
but yeah,
it's true.
Like if you look at like a,
like a playboy model or like a model for
like,
you know,
like black men's magazine or you know,
like a model for Max.
I'm like,
they're like the super fit young women,
you know,
who like have like really good like
muscles and a really curvy.
Yeah,
well people like men are naturally
attracted to women with a certain amount
of body fat.
It's a natural thing to be
healthy.
Like the whole idea of breasts and butts
and hips being attractive is because
genetically women who have those things
will carry children better and we'll be
more likely to be able to nourish those
children because they're healthy.
It's the total genetic thing.
So much so this is the weirdest aspect
of it.
So much so that if a woman has fake
boobs,
like you know,
they're fake,
you know,
there's no disconnect at all.
You're absolutely aware that she has
gone through surgery to cut her skin
stuff.
Bags of water in the air that make them
stick out.
You're like,
oh,
but they stick out more.
Like men will be more attracted sexually
and the sexual attraction is supposed to
at least represent wanting to breed with
that person like you.
You are not just trekked,
you're tricking yourself like it's the
Wa like fake boobs are one of the
weirdest things of all time.
If you really stop and look at,
if we were,
if aliens came down from another planet
or even historians,
because I guarantee you,
like we were talking about like Bradley
Manning and Chelsea Manning,
there's gonna come a time in whatever,
not so distant future the next hundred
years,
but they're just going to be able to
turn you into a woman.
You know,
you're going to say like,
I don't want to be a woman anymore.
I'd like to be a man.
They'll make you a man for a year.
I mean like,
Eh,
I like being molly better.
You go back to me and molly instead of
Mike,
Molly,
and Mike the show,
right?
And you,
I think they going to be able to do that
with press.
They're going to be able to do that with
everything.
They're going to be able to manipulate
genetics to the point where,
um,
if you ever seen or listened to this or
radio lab,
a episode on Crispr,
I hadn't know it,
that crispr is an a new method of
manipulating genetics that they,
that they have invented.
It's a really super complicated thing
that I'm going to butcher,
but they've invented it by studying the
DNA of viruses and they figured out how
to utilize that,
that sort of method to manipulate
eventually at least human dna and the
point where they're going to be able to
change your traits.
They got to make a change.
They're going to be able to change so
many different things,
introduce genes into specific areas of
your body and fix problems or change
things that you don't like.
Are they going to go do some fucking
freaky shit?
And this is just one invention that is,
I think 2012 it was invented and by the
time 2032 rolls around,
who the fuck knows what they're going to
have?
I think we're really close to be able
to,
to just completely manipulate human
bodies.
But the point being when historians go
back and they look at fake boobs,
they're going to be like,
what the fuck were these people doing?
Like how weird is this?
There's going to be a smithsonian that
has like boxes of like silicone and this
is the early days and this was when they
went to céline and you know,
we're going to look at that stuff going,
what a strange time to be alive.
But the thing is though,
like with chicory and like matters of
aesthetics,
I didn't even want to call it trickery.
I mean there's all sorts of like you can
like totally like admire,
like think a guy like looks really hot
and a sharp suit even though you know
it's not really his scan.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's not,
there's,
there's a whole like sort of visual
appreciation of other people that
doesn't necessarily just have to do with
like what's the,
you know,
the quote unquote real or like what's
your genetic heritage?
That's really true.
A closer,
a great exam.
That's a really good example because
that is weird.
Like you see someone who's dressed sharp
and you go,
Ooh man,
he looks great in that suit.
Like that's a beautiful vest.
Like wow,
that looks awesome on him.
That's a strange thing.
Like you look good with stuff on you.
Yeah,
exactly.
It could hang stuff on you that makes
you look good or professional or
authoritive or all of these other
things,
even though like they're just like stuff
that you're wearing.
I wonder if that's a truth.
The same with hermit crabs.
Oh my.
Out a good shell.
Could you imagine like someone's like,
I'm wearing like the really slick cool.
Shall look,
I'm going to get all the girl hermit
crabs right now.
Yeah,
probably right.
There's some weird things in nature with
animals doing things like,
oh,
how about animals that can actually
money.
Have you ever paid attention to octopus
at all?
Um,
[inaudible] you know,
I'm like,
I'm pretty shamefully ignorant.
You might have to educate me here.
I had,
well apparently cuddle
fish are just as bizarre if not more.
But my friend Remy Warren is a,
um,
he's a host of a show called the Apex
Predator where they,
um,
they monitor,
they will,
they sort of,
um,
try to emulate the different attributes
that certain predators have and how they
survive and see like if there's like
some,
a human version of that.
And,
and um,
they,
they like check out like how,
uh,
it's called heroin and that those tall
birds Harun herons,
herons.
How do you say that?
Heron heron herons.
Um,
like how they walk with their crazy long
legs and then stab at the water looking
for like frogs and shit.
And he did one on octopus's and at of
all the different animals we were
talking about,
he was like,
you know,
there's all these cool animals.
They were talking about like how wolves
will chase down packs of elk and how
they cornered them and in these canyons
and draws and how they figured out how
to trap them.
It's really fascinating.
But when he started talking about
octopus,
he's like,
dude,
you have never see our fucking aliens.
Like,
look at these things like what color
they can change their colors.
Like this is real.
They can change their colors and
immediately adapt to their environment
to the point where they're
indistinguishable from the background.
This is amazing.
Oh,
they're insane.
They're insane.
They're there.
They can,
they can instantaneously like within
fractions of a second change the outside
of their body to look exactly like a
coral reef,
not just in the image but in the
texture.
They do all kinds of,
they can change themselves to look more
like predators or like dangerous things.
It's,
it's incredible what they can do.
You live from the coolest world.
My God.
Oh,
the world's amazing.
The world.
The ocean still like,
um,
there's some new project that they're
doing right now.
Um,
or they're trying to map the ocean floor
and there without a doubt they're going
to discover some freaky fucking fish
life marine life down there that we've
never encountered before.
But just these creatures were just
starting to learn what these things are
doing.
Like,
look at that like a flower or something
on fast motion.
That's an octopus.
That's not to be
a Wiki or something looks like,
but watch this,
it,
it can merge with these,
um,
coral reefs and it looks like a coral
reef.
So it's literally developed this ability
to turn his body into the shape of a
reef.
And then it's little tiny.
I mean it's,
it curls,
it's tentacles up into little tiny legs
and runs on two legs.
It's fucking incredible.
They're amazing.
Wow.
And look,
it's like a teardrop shape.
That's so cool.
It's amazing.
He's just octopuses is just cause
they're fun to draw with all the
tentacles and stuff.
But I,
God,
yeah,
I had no idea.
Like the fact that they can do it like
that they just change like fucking what
a weird world and the communicate with
each other somehow through that.
And we don't know how we know they're
really fucking smart though.
Are they going to take it all over after
we destroy everything?
The OCTOPI are going to rule the earth.
Well,
that's something I've been like really
dwelling on lately when it comes to
marine life and dolphins and orcas and
I'm a huge believer that they are just
as intelligent as us,
if not more.
And that what we're doing with seaworld
and all these wild dolphin shows is
nothing less than slavery.
It's slavery of some alien intelligence
that we can't communicate with.
We don't understand what they're saying.
So really,
um,
can hear you.
I don't know what you're saying.
So fucking jumped for fish or starve.
It's your choice.
And um,
I've,
I've thought about it but like our ideas
about what is intelligent,
like we don't think that something's
intelligent and less,
it does exactly what we do.
When we,
when we think of intelligence,
we say,
okay,
well molly,
send me an email.
I sent her an email back.
I know she's intelligent.
She's communicating through an email.
The Dolphin is not a fucking make an
email.
He's an idiot.
You know,
like,
but they don't need email.
Like why do we need email?
We need email cause we need to
communicate well.
They can communicate from miles through
the water with their chirps and their
noises.
They recognize each other from,
you know,
years and years being apart from each
other.
Even though to us,
they all look the fucking same.
They can move and manipulate through
three d space in the water.
They don't need a house because they're
smart enough to go with a water's warm
fishes everywhere and it's free so they
don't need jobs.
So all these ideas that we have is like
what represents intelligence,
all that stuff,
stupid cause to them.
I feel like,
well I'm going to build a house and
drive my car to work.
They're like,
what are you talking about,
bitch or under the water?
Like if you do like,
I need a hoard it all the fish and my
thing and like kill them and then I'll
sell you the fucking fish for calc.
That's a great idea.
They'd be like,
what?
Like your high dolphin.
I'm going to write you a letter from my
laptop was,
there's no internet down here.
Stupid.
There's no like you're a crap dolphin.
Yeah,
you're,
you're fucking laptops,
not gonna work on their water asshole.
So all of our ideas about what,
what's intelligent is only based on our
ability to manipulate or environment or
create things that didn't exist.
So our intelligence is a very bizarre
intelligence because it's,
we the only intelligence that can not
just manipulate our or environment
that's local.
But our environment globally,
like we can,
we can essentially change the weather.
We can spray,
we can cloud seed and make it rain and
put like,
that's one of the weird things they do
in Abu Dhabi.
They make it rain every week.
They do it on purpose.
They spray the sky with some sort of
silver something or another that makes
it,
I don't forget what the exact compound
is,
but it actually causes it to rain.
And they've been doing it like once a
week for years.
They have rainstorms that they
manufacturer,
we're freaks,
we're freaks.
And our intelligence is fundamentally
built on dissatisfaction,
which I mean we have to have,
cause we're also like weak and not apex
predators necessarily.
And we're getting weaker I think too.
I think that's part of it.
You know,
if you went back to the early humans and
you compare it like our tendons and bone
structure and are they,
are they really humans?
Are they,
are they stronger than us?
It was that they were like shorter and
stuff.
The,
her dolls were so not really humans
right there,
like a type of human and the how they
categorize them,
they were way stronger than I was.
So they weren't just stronger than us.
They were like really short.
There were like five foot five foot two
and,
but like 220 pounds just fucking gorilla
like with super thick bones and fic
heads.
And then they don't really know exactly
how intelligent they were either.
This,
all this speculation as to whether or
not they figured out tools on their own
or whether they copied them from Homo
sapiens and where homosapiens came from
and they interbreed and there's debate
on that as well.
And it's a,
and then they're always fun on these,
fucking knew their violin.
Another one,
like within the last couple of weeks
they found another new species of human.
We didn't know existed.
They found some large tooth that,
uh,
turned out to be not category,
it was a human tooth,
but not categorized in any previous
version of human beings that they were
aware of before.
Or if they found quite a few of them
now,
including the,
I'm sure you've heard of like that.
The hobbit people they found the island
of Flores,
that was 14,000 years ago.
That's not that long ago.
No luck.
That's not before the beginning of
recorded history as it,
it's quill.
I always a little bit before,
a little bit depends on whose version of
the beginning of recorded history is.
There's a bought a bunch of people that
believe,
um,
there's this guy that I've had on my
podcast a few times now.
His name's Randall Carlson and he's an
expert in,
um,
cataclysmic events and,
uh,
especially a asteroidal impacts.
And,
uh,
him and this guy,
Graham Hancock have worked together and
Graham Hancock wrote this book called
fingerprints of the Gods.
It was a really controversial book in
the 90s.
And then now he has a new one called
magicians of the gods,
which is sort of shows how much of his
early work that was widely criticized
was actually substantiated now by
science where these ancient structures
that didn't make any sense.
So they were trying to figure out like
who fucking built these and how the WHO
or how they here and archeologists sort
of try to put like vague dates on them.
And the idea behind it was that
civilization has not evolved and it's
not progressed on a,
a straight plane,
but rather there's been these peaks and
valleys.
And then what has happened is people
have gotten this very high level of
sophistication and culture and then
massive cataclysmic disasters have white
people out almost to the brink of
extinction.
And they've arisen back up again.
So like science is like,
found quite a few of them.
But one of the big ones they keep
pointing out is that there's somewhere
around 12,000 years ago,
there was a series of uh,
impacts on the earth and has been proven
by science now because over the last few
years they've discovered this stuff
called,
I think it's called Triton night,
but it's essentially called nuclear
glass.
And it exists around where the,
um,
do nuclear tests and it also at exists
at meteor impact sites and it's,
the impact creates heat that's so
intense.
It turns sand and rock to glass and they
find this stuff all throughout Europe
and all through,
and it's all around the same time
period,
which also coincides with the end of the
ice age.
And it also coincides with a thousand
plus years later,
the beginning of modern civilization,
agriculture,
mathematics.
And so their,
their theory is that that wasn't exactly
the beginning,
but that was a rebirth.
And if there was most likely thousands
of years of civilization that existed
before that,
but it was almost entirely wiped out
when people are just bombarded with
rocks from the sky.
I mean it makes a lot of sense,
especially when societies where less
interconnected,
like the whole reason you know stuff
various like you know,
math or astrology survived the dark ages
in Europe was because in the Middle East
people were able to keep it alive.
We live in a time now where unless they
literally wiped out everyone,
it'd be very hard to do that.
But in a world where people don't have
that level of communication where they
don't have that level of connection
where they don't have that level of
knowledge sharing,
it would be very easy for one society to
kind of,
you know,
get to that peak and then something
horrifying happening to it and no other
societies could carry on that legacy.
Yeah,
I mean it would be pretty easy,
especially today in our culture because
everything has become digital.
It's one of the weirdest things about us
advancing and evolving is that as things
move to the cloud and as things become
much,
much less physical books like your book
here,
but much more like laptops and kindle
Kendall and it has 150 books on or
something like that.
It's that thin.
It just sits right in my backpack.
I mean the what,
that's crazy.
It's crazy.
It's like this magicians thing.
But also you could potentially like drop
a server that had the only copy of
something and have that only copy
disappear.
Yeah.
And if the power goes out,
you're not getting any of this stuff.
I had a friend who was um,
he was going back into an area where he
couldn't bring books cause there are
checkpoints and um,
had a lot of,
and he um,
had uh,
his itunes account with something that
like,
it just,
you,
the country that was tied to you
couldn't buy good ebooks on.
So I remember I was getting him,
I got him all these pirated copies of
like 1984 and like James Baldwin and
catch 22 and stuff to read and it,
you know,
he only has like a few hours of power a
day and he's like reading like 1984 on
his phone.
And it was like the craziest
illustration of both the like ubiquity
of,
you know,
a book and also the limits of it in this
sort of cloud edge.
Yeah.
There's a lot of limits of it.
Our entire society is dependent upon the
grid.
If the grid goes down,
almost none of this stuff is effective,
but by the same token,
he could smuggle all these books,
past checkpoints and no one knew he had.
Yeah.
Right.
No,
I mean there's,
there's definitely,
if you're in a war torn area like that,
it's a great,
it's just,
to me,
it,
it freaks me out when I think of,
if something like that happened.
Like there was,
um,
a big event,
I think it was in Indonesia and at
70,000 years ago,
they think that civilization was wiped
out to the point of there being only a
couple thousand people left on the
planet.
Yeah.
Super Volcano erupted.
Um,
if anything remotely like that happened,
we would instantaneously be brought
right back to where people were 50,000
years ago.
Well,
most of us don't have any sort of skills
to maintain or rebuild anything.
I mean,
I don't,
I,
I know if there like the Zombie
apocalypse,
I,
I'd be like fucking food or something.
Yeah.
And what if we broke into a home depot?
Like there's a home depot that's like a
few miles from here.
How many fucking people could get a
hammer from there?
There's a lot of people out here,
you know,
this is not enough.
There's not enough hammers.
Yeah.
I mean,
we wouldn't even,
we'd hope the shelters that we have hold
up,
but then where are we going to get food?
Like what do,
unless we get into the ocean and go
fishing,
like what are you gonna get to shoot
deer?
How many deer?
They're like five and this whole
neighborhood,
you know.
Well it's the level of population
density we have could never be supported
by like traditional agriculture ever.
Not Anymore.
No.
It's weird.
You know what else is weird?
The friend of mine pointed this out.
He goes,
why is it that when you walked on the
street you see all these plants but none
of them grow food.
Like everyone grows plants everywhere.
But there are all these fucking useless
plants.
Like what?
Wouldn't it be amazing if like cities
were filled with plants that grow fruit
and all the,
the grasses and stuff he saw were edible
and there was lettuce everywhere.
Like literally everything had food on
it.
Like it would be just the same amount of
water used,
but you would actually get something out
of it.
But we're so rich,
they were like,
nope.
Pine trees.
No,
I want to oak,
I want a beautiful oak here.
Like we don't,
you know,
we don't support the,
the,
the trees and the plants around us that
we can actually eat.
I remember one time I was in um,
Spain and I was like 17,
it was broke and I was with my,
my,
my friend and we saw like,
wow,
he's orange,
cheesy,
steal a lot of oranges to be like,
climb up the tree and be like,
steal all the oranges.
And then we like peel them and then
they're like bitter and dry and we're
like,
these are fucking decorative oranges.
They tricked us.
They tricked us with their there.
These oranges are lies.
And I,
I think that they specifically probably
planted those type of oranges to avoid
bad people like us climbing the trees
and stealing all of them.
Is that funny?
You're a bad person because you're doing
what people have done for the last week.
Exactly.
Yeah.
We're bad person for picking fruit from
a tree.
How strange.
This is w and it's also probably those
were what orange is really tasted like
before we start fucking with them.
I refuse to believe that that's a cruel
world.
Well,
they,
they know that the fact for like corn,
a lot of other food was like really
gross before people started manipulating
it.
Truth,
truth,
but orange is,
I want to,
I want to believe that like prehistoric
oranges were a tasty treat and these
were not,
I dunno,
I,
I ate an apple the other day and me and
my friends were laughing more eating
these apples were like,
these fucking things have definitely
been fucked with like there were big,
big giant and they were so juicy.
We're like,
what kind of genetically modified shit
are we eating right now?
Because these are just not normal
apples.
Giant juicy,
delicious apples.
Probably in like the middle of apple off
season two.
Yeah,
probably.
Do you ever had a crab apple,
molly crab apple?
I have a photo of Mandurah crab apple
tree,
but I don't,
I don't know if her friend took that
one.
I don't know if I've ever eaten the crab
apple man.
I,
I'm sure this will get remedied someday,
but uh,
not,
not yet.
I don't think.
Really.
Yeah,
I mean I,
oh no,
you're,
oh my God.
You're right.
God,
I'm getting like deep into the memory
bank.
When I was seven and I lived in far
rockaway.
I think one of the neighbors had a crab
apple tree or it had the tree with the
little apples.
There's the ground,
the crab apples.
And I believe that,
um,
I believe I stole some of them and I
believe they're very sour.
Yeah,
I remember them.
they're very sour.
I ate one of those when I was a little
kid.
Well more than once.
I'm sure when I was a little kid growing
up from Massachusetts,
I remember biting into those things.
Oh yeah.
So much hope.
Yeah,
the good they're throwing at people
though.
That's what we use them for.
The kids taste nice.
Chuck them at each other.
Small and hard like,
yeah.
Well you know your little tiny hands and
get a good grip on the crab apple new
whip it.
Nice.
Um,
what else you got going on these days
besides,
I know you're promoting this book and
uh,
besides that,
so I'm going to really excited
about this.
I'm going to India for a month cause
there's all these literary festivals in
India,
so I'm getting to good.
Yeah,
I'm getting to it.
Like Dji pour and Mumbai and ben before.
No,
it's my first time in my life.
So I'm really excited about that.
And then besides that,
you know,
I think I'm reaching that point of
burnout where I,
and just,
I'm like actually planning to take a
month off.
I know it sounds like fun.
It sounds like fucking blast for me,
but I think I,
I'm going to like lie on a beach and go
or something and read a lot of books.
And other than that,
the only thing I really have to talk
about is my super dork hobby,
which is a,
um,
I've been studying,
literary Arabic for the last year and I
got pretty good at translating stuff.
Written stuff.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm really pretty proud of it.
I do this every morning.
Uh,
so I'm translating,
uh,
like long dialogue by the Syrian poet
that's called sex poetry in the
revolution and it is bad ass.
But other than that,
I,
I think I'm actually going into that
lake time where I'm just making like a
little blank space.
And then at the end of that I'll
probably be back doing a bunch of
journalism for vice doing stuff on
prisons in the Middle East working on my
next book project and I don't know,
seeing,
seeing where life goes cause thing
that's so strange about doing a memoir
or is it really is like sectioning off
at chapter six section off,
you know,
15 years of your life and then you've
taken all of that and you've put it into
this book for him.
You've made it into an object and then
you go onto what's next.
And I,
I guess while I have the vague contours
of that in my head,
part of me just wants to do nothing for
awhile and then the plan will come to
me.
I think that's a great idea.
I'm,
I'm thinking the same thing about my own
life right now.
I think I'm too involved and too many
different things and I could use a
reset,
like a calming as to,
I think you get that.
It's all good stuff and that's the
problem and I think that's what you're
experiencing as well.
Like,
you have so many cool things you have
going on.
Awesome.
I feel so lucky.
Yeah.
But it's,
but if there's no space,
I mean can absorb them.
Yeah.
It's like that,
that Louis C K thing about like never
being bored,
you know?
I mean I have that in the best of all
possible ways.
I have like so many cool opportunities,
but if you never have like any,
any time to like be bored or be down,
you're just like bouncing from thing to
thing and yeah,
I think,
yeah.
Louis C K thing about never being born.
I'm not aware of it.
Uh,
it was like a monologue that he had a,
about where he was saying that since we
have smartphones,
basically we just,
right now I remember it.
Yeah.
So you never had like any space to feel
anything or to,
or to be bored.
And so you're just always in a state of
distraction.
And I think it can be like that with
work stuff too.
So after that,
probably just probably just doing a
bunch of journalism stuff.
I work a lot with a really cool,
I'm Syrian American nonprofit that I'm
going to plug here.
They're called a cutter.
I'm foundation and I'm they k a r a m
and they do something really cool
because a lot attention right now it's
on the Syrian refugees that make it to
Europe,
but they actually work with people who
are displaced inside Syria.
And then also people like on the border.
And for the last two years,
uh,
I've taken part in a program with them
where we go down to the schools that are
on the border and they bring like,
they bring the dentists,
the fix all the kids' teeth.
They,
uh,
bring up I doctors that get all the kids
glasses that need it,
but then they also bring like writers
and philosophers and architects and
like,
you know,
people who teach classes with the kids.
And I was a,
I always do murals there.
I've done murals in two schools now and
so next spring I'll probably be back
with them a painting,
lots of rebellious cats all over a
school in southeast Turkey.
Wow.
You live such a low ball,
broad and fascinating life.
I mean you've had so many really intense
experiences and and,
and all over the place,
like about both,
all the place professionally and
creatively.
And then geographically there's so much
going on.
Like you,
you,
you're not living a boring life.
No,
I feel so lucky.
I mean that's why it's so hard for me to
be,
I need to take a reset because it's like
the whole world is so big and cool and I
love so many things in it.
Yeah.
But I think,
I think your instincts are correct
though.
He's just,
it seems to me like you're just,
you've got so much going on all the
time.
Constantly in so many different arenas.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a lot.
But I don't know.
Must be,
it must be the same with you too.
I mean like you d ina,
you do comedy,
you do this like super like thoughtful
talk thing.
Do you like host MMA stuff?
You mean you've done like so many
fucking things and I mean it's just
cause like I feel perhaps you feel this
way.
Like the world is just so big and weird
and interesting and like I just want to
like learn stuff.
Yeah.
I wish I could live 10 different lives
simultaneously and have a bunch of
different careers that I'd be interested
in.
Same.
Exactly.
But it's like to do any of those things
correctly requires so much attention and
focus.
It's almost like you can't,
you can enjoy too many things cause you
then the one thing that you enjoy the
most or that you choose to enjoy the
most,
he really can't focus on it correctly
or else you just never ever,
ever have downtime ever.
Yeah,
I'm close to that.
I get close to that sometimes but it's
not good.
But it's weird because like my non
downtime seems very recreational.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's Super Fun.
Like I don't want to like complain like
wow,
I get to travel all over the world and
meet fascinating people in Confront
Bastards Boohoo for me.
And yet he didn't,
you know,
it at a certain,
at a certain point,
you know,
um,
this is a big compliment,
but I'm a,
and I don't mean this in terms of an
imitation,
but your,
your drawing of trump and Ivanka was
very ralph steadman s
oh,
I idolize that guy.
I love him.
No,
that's it.
That's a massive compliment.
Like I think that man is like a God
amongst men.
He's a bad motherfucker for sure.
But that image is just so much like,
I think of it as like a,
the Kentucky Derby is decadent.
Yeah.
Monster like toad people.
Oh yeah.
I've got that on framed on my wall,
my office,
a print from a stubbins illustration of
the Kentucky Derby.
Cool.
Have you ever had,
have you ever like had him on the
shower?
Do you want to get in Ken?
I would love to.
I mean,
I don't know if he's ever in Los
Angeles,
but I prefer to do these things in
person.
But if he's ever here,
I would love to have much to talk to him
about a hunter and what it looks like
and what does last at for time hundred
dose and with acid.
Oh,
when they,
when they went to,
when they went to the rumble in the
jungle and hunter like sold their
tickets and,
and he was like drawing and off the TV
screen.
Yeah.
He was swimming in the pool and he
totally fucked the whole story up
because he thought that one was going to
kill Muhammad Ali and he didn't want to
see it.
So you put a Richard Nixon mask on and
swam around the yeah,
the bull.
He to this day over,
well not to this day,
obviously he's dead,
but considered that one of his biggest
journalistic failures and he went into a
giant slump after he did that because
like he realized that his decadence and
his indulgence had actually gotten in
the way of an amazing moment in history.
God just to realize like the fucking
like beautiful beast that like you rode
to being who you were.
Like it was turning around and like
becoming like a sort of cliche that was
fucking up everything.
You liked it.
Well that's what the,
did you ever see the uh,
Alex Gibney movie?
Uh,
Gonzo,
the life and times of Dr. Hunter is
fucking incredible.
It's so good.
It's such a good documentary.
But that was almost like initially
that's how they started the movie off.
He started the movie off explaining that
at the end of his life,
hunter had really stopped being
creative.
The writing wasn't there anymore.
The things that he wrote were like
really a middling,
they weren't that good and it was
because his indulgences and his excesses
had really cooked his brain and he just
had,
he had become almost a caricature of
himself and along the lines,
some of the interviews they had found
him when he was a younger man and when
he had started to become famous and he
was actually worried about that very
thing.
You were saying like,
I,
I can't even get out of my own way
anymore and they don't even necessarily
when I'm,
when I'm doing these things,
I can't tell whether or not they want me
and they want my take on things or
whether they want the reality itself
like an I,
I'm,
he goes,
it's almost,
it would almost be better if I died like
for my own work.
And that was like,
wow,
this guy is like experiencing like a
really early version of both.
Also very rare that a journalist's
becomes that famous,
so,
so rare,
so rare.
But I mean,
I think the problem was that he,
at a certain point,
he stopped growing and changing and
pushing himself and it was just more
comfortable to like stay in the mask.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
and also the indulgences and the
substances became not just a habit but a
physical addiction.
And at that point in time,
he's more of a slave to that than he is.
Even though the work itself and the work
itself is almost like something that
he's eventually going to get to.
I'll get to that eventually.
I'll get to that,
but it's just cocaine and we read off a
list when Lance Armstrong was here
yesterday of a typical day in the life
of hunter s Thompson as far as,
oh God.
Yeah.
It just starts with like massive.
What it does it start with like ether or
coke.
What does it start with?
Starts with a sh.
It's like chivas regal cocaine.
Dunhill cigarettes,
cocaine.
Chivas.
Regal caught me like we read it all off.
It's fucking preposterous.
Like you should be fucking dead.
And then it says at midnight,
hunter s Thompson is ready to write and
this is like after getting up at three
God,
you spend your entire time like pouring
liquids into your head and then smoking
things.
But for a while it worked.
Man.
He wrote some insane shit during that
time.
He wrote some amazing stuff for,
it's almost like he just red lined his
brain,
never changed the oil and kept the metal
ground down.
I got it.
Be Boring and I got to go.
I'm really sorry to hear.
All right,
well thank you.
No,
please.
No worries.
Thank you so much for coming on.
And everybody drawing blood is the book.
I'm in the middle of it right now and it
is excellent and your writing is really
fantastic and honest and,
and just really,
really good stuff.
Thank you.
And,
uh,
you can follow molly on twitter.
Molly crab,
apple on twitter.
Same thing on instagram.
A website,
crab apple.com go by the book fuckers.
Thank you.
Thanks Molly.
Bye everybody.